Das ist das, was ich als Difficulty 5 Geocache nenne. Und ich denke, das war diese. Siehst du sie? Ihr hört CRE, Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und das hier ist die 204. Ausgabe von CRE. Ein Programm, was häufiger aktualisiert werden könnte, aber nichtsdestotrotz nicht vergessen wurde von mir. Und ja, weiter geht's. Weiter geht's mit einem schönen Thema, wie ich finde, was sagen wir mal hier auch so dieser gesetzten Trinität, Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft mal wieder schön nahe rückt. Konkret soll es gehen um Geocaching oder sagen wir mal vielleicht ein bisschen weiter gesteckt auch so das Leben mit dem Draußen im digitalen Zeitalter. Ja, und um da mal ausführlich reinzustochen und mal zu gucken, was QUIC macht, wenn man nachschaut, begrüße ich Regine. Regine Heidorn, hallo.
Hallo.
Was tut man denn da?
Du cached oder du geocachedst. Du suchst, ich sammle Dosen.
Okay, du bist Dosen-Sammlerin?
Ja, es gibt ja zum Beispiel in Norddeutschland auch die Dosenfischer. Die machen auch einen geocaching-Podcast. Und so Events auch und so. Also Dosen.
Dosen sammeln? Ja, Dosen sind wichtig. Ich weiß nicht genau, warum. Vielleicht ändert sich das ja auch noch. Aber bevor wir auf dieses Thema kommen, vielleicht noch mal kurz zu dir. Du bist ja, ich weiß nicht, du machst gern draußen Aktivität, oder? Kann man das so sagen?
Ja, ganz schlimm.
Bist du ein Outdoor-Mensch?
Ja, also früher mal mehr, aber jetzt gibt's ja Internet und Computer. Nee, aber wenn man mich fragen würde, was für Hobbys ich habe, dann dürften das tatsächlich überwiegend draußen Hobbys sein. Motorradfahren, Fahrradfahren, Geocaching, sehr viel gewandert früher auch. Ja, doch, schon relativ viel draußen. Aber ich lese auch gerne, ich habe früher mal sehr viel Gitarre gespielt, ich höre auch gerne Musik, also, aber das kann man ja auch alles draußen machen. Oder drinnen oder so.
Ja, vor allem Gitarre spielen. Mit den frisch gesammelten Dosen um sich herum.
Nee, das war früher mit einem Fahrtfinder.
Sammeln die eigentlich auch irgendwas ein? Was machen die eigentlich?
Fahrtfinder?
Ja, die laufen eigentlich nur rum, oder?
Ja, nee, schon noch ein bisschen mehr. Also es ist schon noch mehr so Community und sich persönlich kennenlernen. Ja, aber es ist schon viel, sich in real life treffen. Also Fahrtfinder online ist möglich, aber vielleicht nicht so erstrebenswert.
Ja gut, aber irgendwie diese Hobbys, also vielleicht nicht unbedingt das Gitarre spielen, aber was ich so ein bisschen drin stecke, also was für mich drin steckt, was ich da so sehe, ist schon so ein gewisser Wunsch auch, wie sagt man, dieses, real life ist so ein Scheißwort, das kann man irgendwie echt nicht mehr benutzen, aber so dieses Draußensein auch wirklich so mit irgendwas zu verbinden, um es dann auch ein bisschen wertvoller zu machen. Also das ist vielleicht auch so ein bisschen so eine Nerdeigenschaft, weiß nicht ganz genau, also ich hab auch gerne so früher so gewandert, das war für mich auch was, aber die eigentliche Herausforderung oder wie soll ich sagen, ein extra Reiz lag für mich da drin, während des Wanderns auch die ganze Zeit möglichst genau zu wissen, wo ich bin. Also ich hatte unheimlich viel investiert in Karten, ja, ich bin also, was weiß ich, 80er Jahre, da gab es ja noch nichts in digital, da musste man sich so mehrere Kilogramm topografische Karten holen und es war für mich immer eine totale Genugtuung, irgendwo auf irgendeinem Hügel zu sein und dann dieses kleine, eingezeichnete Etwas, was auch immer dieses Symbol ist, dann auch konkret zu finden und darüber hinaus mir auch extrem darüber bewusst zu sein, wo ich jetzt gerade bin, wohin ich schaue. Wenn ich jetzt so hier an diesen drei Hügeln vorbeischaue, so habe ich dann auch wirklich so genau die Flucht von dem, wo ich dahin will oder sehe ich, wenn ich nach hinten schaue, noch das, wo ich vor zwei Stunden war, keine Ahnung, also das hat mich immer so, mich persönlich immer so gefangen genommen. Und das war dann für mich so ein, wie sagt man so schön, added value, ja. Also das hat für mich den Reiz des Wanderns erhöht, wenn nicht vielleicht sogar erst ausgemacht. Und diese ganzen digitalen Spiele mit was finden und so, naja. Gab es Geocaching auch schon vor?
Geocaching ist tatsächlich mit dem GPS gekommen und auch genau aus dieser Motivation heraus, also aus so einer Nerd-Ecke, wo dann eben so ein Couch-Potato, also zumindest die Legende auch mal dachte so, ja, wir haben jetzt diese Geräte, das ist ja interessant für ein technikaffines Publikum. Da könnte man doch zum Beispiel im Internet mal Koordinaten hinterlegen und dann dort was hinterlegen. Und dann könnte man ja mal gucken, ob da jemand hingeht.
Aber es gab schon immer diese Wanderhütten, wo man dann so hinkommt, was ja auch so definierte Orte sind, die man auch erstmal finden musste, wo dann auch nicht selten immer noch was zu finden war, was andere da jetzt hinterlassen hatten.
Das Hüttenbuch?
Hüttenbuch, genau. Gipfelbuch? Gipfelbuch.
Ja, am Gipfelkreuz?
Ja, oder auch so natürlich so Nahrungsmittel, die sie nicht mehr brauchten, keine Ahnung, aber auch haben wir so kleine Dinge, die einfach zurückgelassen wurden, aus welchen Motivationen auch immer. Also vielleicht war das so ein bisschen auch so eine Motivation.
Im Gegensatz zu Geocaching ist ja das Schöne an den Hütten, dass man dort selten zum Beispiel Überraschungseilfiguren in Massen hinterlassen hat, wie du die zum Beispiel in Geocaches findest.
In Massen? Okay, also es gab auf jeden Fall da schon so was Neues auf einmal, weil die Welt auf einmal, auf einmal könnte man die Welt anders erschließen.
Es gab ja auch schon einen Vorläufer von Geocaching, das sogenannte Letterboxing Mitte des 18. Jahrhunderts. Da haben Leute sich quasi diese, also bei Zahlen darf es mich nicht ganz genau festlegen, aber das habe ich so ungefähr Mitte des 18. Jahrhunderts im Sinn. Da haben Leute diese sogenannten Listings auch schon geschrieben, die heißen, also wenn man eine Geocache Beschreibung hat, dann heißt es heute auch noch Listing. Und haben die halt auf Papier geschrieben, haben die kopiert und haben sich halt getroffen, die untereinander ausgetauscht und das waren auch eigentlich, also wie ich das verstanden habe und gibt es auch immer noch heute Letterboxing-Communities auch. Es ist auch nichts anderes als eine Beschreibung von, ja, weiß ich nicht, du gehst in Berlin zum Alexanderplatz, dann gehst du zur Weltzeituhr, dann peilst du mit deinem Kompass so und so viel Grad irgendwo hin, gehst dann zehn Schritte und findest da im Mauerwerk versteckt oder was?
Zackes, Schatzsuche. Für mich ist das so ein bisschen Piratenschatzkarte irgendwie. 1854.
Ah ja, Mitte 19.
Hassend benannter Mensch, William Crossing.
Das heißt doch jetzt Xing.
Das erinnert sich an die Zeit, nicht wahr? Genau, und der hat das irgendwie im Dartmoor gemacht, ist ja auch so ein Ort, wo man schön laufen kann.
Nee, aber die erste Letterbox hieß bestimmt, der Mörder ist immer der Gärtner oder so.
Auf jeden Fall, Letterbox im Sinne von wie so eben, also so wie diese Briefkästen, diese Gartenbriefkästen, die halt so etwas für sich solitär stehen, gut wettergeschützt zum Aufmachen und da war dann halt irgendwie was drin. Na das ist doch mal wirklich eine historische Vorlage fast, könnte man sagen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also man kann das Letterboxing auch mit GPS betreiben, man kann aber offensichtlich das Geocaching auch ohne die Technik betreiben.
Ist das nicht auch in England losgetreten worden?
Amerika.
Das wäre natürlich jetzt sehr naheliegend gewesen. Okay, kommen wir vielleicht noch mal so ein bisschen auf den eigentlichen Punkt. Also wir reden über Geocaching. Geocaching ist ein Hobby, kann man das so sagen? Ein Hobby, was man betreiben kann oder nicht. Und wenn man es betreibt, dann lässt man sich Orte geben, findet Beschreibungen von Orten meistens mehr oder weniger konkret mit Geokoordinaten. Und dann ist die Aufgabe, diesen Ort dann auch zu finden und dort den Schatz auszugraben.
Ja, graben, da wird es schon schwierig. Aber ich fange jetzt mal vielleicht von vorne an. Also es gibt erstmal auf jeden Fall eine Plattform, die sozusagen den Service anbietet, dass du überhaupt Geocaches finden kannst. Dass du, wenn du Geocaches legst, also wenn du ein sogenannter Geocache-Owner bist, ist der richtige Fachbegriff dafür, dann möchtest du ja auch irgendwo kundtun, dass du den Cache gelegt hast. Das heißt, du brauchst natürlich schon eine gewisse Community. Und so der Platzhirsch und das Urgestein ist eigentlich geocaching.com. So, diese Plattform wird betrieben von der Firma GroundSpeak. Und da kann man sich jetzt entweder einen Account holen, der ist in der Regel kostenfrei. Und damit kann man eigentlich auch schon loslegen. Also das praktische an Geocaching ist, dass es in seiner einfachsten Form eigentlich nicht viel braucht und eigentlich auch nicht kostenintensiv ist. Also der Basis-Account kostet nichts. Man braucht natürlich das GPS, aber man hat es entweder sowieso in seinem Smartphone oder man kann eben schon mit einem sehr günstigen Basisgerät einfach auch losgehen cashen. Ich habe mal einen Couchsurfer aus Litauen gehabt. Der hat über 700 Caches gefunden ohne GPS. Der hat sich vorher angeguckt, wo die sind, hat sich Google Maps Screenshots in seinen Handy gezogen, hat sich das als Bild angeguckt, hat sich darauf wie auf einer Karte orientiert und hat anhand dessen die Caches gefunden. Also ohne GPS, ohne Internet.
Ist das so schwierig?
Ich finde es schon eine bemerkenswerte Leistung, weil du auf jeden Fall schon Karten lesen musst. Du hast nicht diese Funktion des GPS, dass du sehen kannst, Luftlinie noch 120 Meter in die Richtung. Das kannst du ja nicht sehen. Du musst ja sozusagen, er hat es eigentlich wie eine Karte gemacht, wo sein Ziel dann eingetragen war, wie du das eingangs auch geschildert hast. Er kam dann dahin an diesen Punkt und dann hat er das gefunden. Vielleicht solltest du Geocaching mal so betreiben.
Ich habe das noch überhaupt nicht betrieben. Ich kann aber nicht genau sagen, warum mich das bisher noch nicht so gereizt hat. Vielleicht war das einfach so diese Vermutung, dass ich mir dachte, wenn man ein GPS-Gerät benutzt, ist das ja so ein bisschen geschummelt. Dann schon lieber so eine richtige Schatzkarte. Also wenn das so, wie du das vorhin so beschrieben hast, hier über die Brücke und dann mit der Liane über die Schlucht hangeln, nur noch dann in der Tonne den Wasserfall herunter und dann sind es nur noch fünf Kilometer Wanderung. Vielleicht hätte das dann noch einen größeren Sinn. Aber ist es denn immer so schwierig oder ist es denn immer so leicht, diese Caches zu finden, wie ich mir das jetzt gerade vorstelle?
Ja, also viele, denen ich davon erzähle, die sagen halt auch, ja, ist ja auch voll langweilig so. Mit dem GPS, das hat ja mittlerweile eine wahnsinnig hohe Genauigkeit. Dann steht man ja schon drauf, wo ist jetzt der Spaß an der ganzen Geschichte. Der Spaß fängt da an, wo man zum Beispiel Geocaches findet, ohne sie gesucht zu haben. Das ist mir schon zweimal im Leben passiert. Einmal kamen wir in so einem alten Vogelhäuschen vorbei und haben gesagt, Mensch, da müsste man eigentlich einen Cache hinlegen, reingegriffen, Dose in der Hand gehabt. Wir konnten nicht mal herausfinden, welcher Cache das war, weil im Logbuch keine GC-Nummer steht. Also jeder Geocache hat eine Unique ID, die sogenannte GC-Nummer. GC für Geocache. Wir konnten ihn sozusagen dann nicht loggen. Und vor kurzem war ich ein Wochenende in Thüringen, da haben wir uns einen Lost Place angeguckt, also so ein verlassenes runtergekommenes, ich glaube, es war ein ehemaliges Schwulgebäude mit so, hat so ein bisschen Eindruck gemacht von so Berufsschule mit Werkstätten dabei. Dann sind wir da so drin rumgestreucht und irgendwann haben wir alle gesagt, wir müssen jetzt unbedingt noch da hinten in diesen aufs Kuhl komischen Lagerraum rein. Dann haben wir gesagt, das kann doch, es waren lauter Geocacher, es kann doch gar nicht sein, dass hier keine Dose ist, hier muss eine Dose sein. Dann haben wir über das Smartphone alle geguckt und da waren aber keine Koordinaten da. Dann sagte ich, naja, da hinten ist noch ein Mystery-Cache, da erkläre ich gleich, was das ist. Vielleicht ist es der, wir rennen da in diesen Raum rein und haben die Dose in der Hand. Zum Beispiel. Geht auch. Zufall. Dann gibt es, also es gibt erstens verschiedene Cache-Arten, das ist ja eben schon mal so ein bisschen angeklungen. Dann gibt es auch zu jedem Cache eine Beschreibung und die sagt halt was darüber aus, erstens was für eine Art von Caches ist, vielleicht die Koordinaten, wenn die schon aufgrund der Art des Caches bekannt gegeben werden dürfen, aber auch noch drei weitere Werte, nämlich einen sogenannten D-Wert für Difficulty, Schwierigkeit 1 bis 5, ein T-Wert für Terrain 1 bis 5 und die Angabe darüber, wie groß die Dose ist. Das geht von Nano. Nano sind so kleine, magnetische, fiese Dinger, die haben so ungefähr Daumennagelgröße. Über Mikro, das ist so die typische Filmdose, sagt man so. Man findet da auch oft Filmdosen. Bis hin zu Regular oder es gab auch Leute, die haben schon ein ganzes Haus als Final genommen. Final ist dann die letztendliche Dose, die man findet. Also tatsächlich der analoge Cash, den man da materialisiert in der Hand hält.
Final, also der Inhalt?
Ja, die finale Dose, da wo du letzten Endes ankommst.
Finale Dose und es gibt noch andere Dosen, die nicht final sind?
Nein, es gibt unterschiedliche Cash-Arten. Und zwar gibt es den Tradi, also Traditional Cash. Das ist so das einfachste. Du guckst auf der Webseite, siehst die Koordinaten, weißt, da muss ich hingehen und da ist auch die Dose. Er ist easy. Dann hat der eben noch seinen D- und T-Wert. Der D-Wert eben, difficulty Schwierigkeit, steht dafür, wie schwer der zu finden ist, wie gut der getarnt ist. Es gibt Geocaches, du stehst davor, guckst drauf und du siehst sie einfach nicht. Und das wirstest du natürlich gerne vorher, was dich da erwartet. Ist das eher so was Einfaches zu mitnehmen, was du schnell siehst?
Muss man das angeben oder ist das optional?
Das musst du angeben. Und der T-Wert ist eben, wie schwierig der vom Terrain her zu erreichen ist. Also T1 wäre zum Beispiel, du musst den normalen geflasterten Gehweg nicht verlassen. Musst du aber den Gehweg schon verlassen, einen Schritt daneben in die Wiese machen, wäre es zum Beispiel schon T1-5er. Geht es hoch zum T5er, wo du dann Spezialausrüstung brauchst, Kletterausrüstung zum Beispiel, Taucherausrüstung.
Das hast du ganz klar definiert, welche Anforderungen mit den einzelnen Zahlen verbunden ist. Also gibt es da eine klare Skala, aus der man herauslesen kann, was jetzt dieser Wert ist, oder ist das mehr so wie mit den 5 Sternen im Internet?
Nee, es gibt schon Richtlinien. Also GroundSpeak versucht dann schon den Cash-Ownern, oder wenn man halt selber einen Cash legen will, Hilfe an die Hand zu geben, wonach man sich ausrichten könnte, oder was man auf jeden Fall nehmen sollte, wenn bestimmte Kriterien schon mal erfüllt sind.
Ja, bleiben wir doch mal kurz dabei. Also ich lege jetzt irgendwo was ab. Was machen wir zuerst? Bleiben wir noch mal bei dem Terrain. Also eins, Baumild an einem Laternenmast von meiner Nase rum.
Oder Telefonzellen-Caches sind auch sehr beliebt. Geocaching ist am Anfang immer super aufregend. Ich weiß noch den ersten Geocache, aber ich habe davon schon ganz früh gehört, in den 90ern habe ich in einem Outdoor-Laden gearbeitet. Da hatten wir dann Ende der 90er, die mit oder Ende der 90er, meine ich, werden in die ersten GPS-Geräte rausgekommen. Die haben dann irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, damals noch 1000 Mark oder sowas gekostet. Das war echt Hightech und ich fand das voll doof, weil ich dachte, wieso? Karte und Kompass, das ist doch viel cooler. Da hat man was zu tun und da gehen die Batterien nicht leer. Und damals war ja auch das Signal noch viel gestörter wegen der US-Armee und so weiter. Und irgendwann dann, 2000 war ja dann auch so dieses Internet Mainstream, dann hörte ich so, ich glaub, so 2002, 2003 zum ersten Mal so, ja Geocaching und so und das ist jetzt voll der heiße Scheiß und das muss man machen und so. Und ich war so, Mann, so blöde Technik-Fetischisten, müssen die da mit ihren Geräten in der Landschaft rumrennen? Und mir war es schon voll unheimlich, als ich auf einer Wanderung zum ersten Mal, weiß ich nicht, wann das war, muss auch so mit der Ende der 90er gewesen sein, dass ich zum ersten Mal vom, am Lagerfeuer stand am Fluss und mit dem Handy meine Mama angerufen hab, so, ja. Da dachte ich schon so, ne, also irgendwas läuft hier falsch, so Herr, das geht so nicht. Ja und ich glaube...
Das sind die Wings of Future-Momente, ne?
Ja, also das war ganz komisch. Und ich hab natürlich auch gesagt, du Mama, ich steh hier grade am Lagerfeuer, ne, am Flussufer. Und ich telefonier mit dir. Wie man das halt so als brave Tochter-Mama so erzählt. Naja, also jedenfalls, ich war, ich glaube 2008 oder 2009 fing ich an mit dem Geocaching. Und die Situation war folgende, ich hatte damals eine Beziehung mit Sohn. Und Sohn und ich haben sich an einem Sonntag gelangweilt. Und war aber auch irgendwie so ein bisschen Technikaffinität und GPS-Geräte waren im Haus und so weiter. Und dann bin ich irgendwann mal zur Sohnummern rüber und habe gesagt, wollen wir nicht einfach mal einen Geocacher suchen gehen?
Wie alt war der Sohn?
Ich glaube 11 oder 12 damals. Ja, und dann sind wir losgegangen und haben also erstmal im Netz so geguckt, was wäre denn in der Nähe? Und dann ganz genau das Ding studiert, weil wir wollten ja auch irgendwie, also wir wollten ja was finden können, so und haben dann versucht irgendwie rauszufinden, was uns da erwarten könnte und können wir das machen und so. Und dann haben wir eben angefangen mit einem Trady 11, ne?
Einfach so finden.
Mikrofilmdose, fertig.
Man weiß dann etwa, was man sucht.
Genau.
Und die Frequenz ist auch niedrig. Also 11, aber bezieht sich jetzt auf das Terra?
11 sagt D1T1.
Ach so, nicht 1,1, sondern okay, verstehe.
Beides 1. Genau, die Werte sind immer in 1,5.
Abgestuft.
Genau. Ja, und dann liefen wir los und haben den auch gefunden. Und haben uns dann einen Account zugelegt zusammen. Und haben dann ganz stolz unseren ersten Cash eingetragen. Und dann fanden wir es irgendwie toll. Und waren irgendwie so ein bisschen angefixen. Dann haben wir gleich losgegangen, haben noch eingeholt. Also Berlin ist ja voll mit Geocaches. Berlin ist echt geflastert.
Aber was ist denn drin in den Dosen?
Ja, ist eine gute Frage. Also, ganz früher war halt der Spaß tatsächlich auch mal oder in den Anfängen des Geocachings, also große Dosen abzulegen, wo du auch wirklich was reinlegen kannst. Und da gab es eben auch wirklich noch ein bisschen konsequenter diese Tauschkultur. Das ist auch so was. Also Tauschen immer gleichwertig. Also wenn du was rausnimmst aus dem Cash, dann tu auch wieder was rein und tu halt was Gleichwertiges rein, damit da kein Downgrading stattfindet. Oder was höherwertig ist natürlich gerne. Ich hab schon gehört von Freaks, die haben dann irgendwie superschwer zu erreichende Cashes irgendwo hingelegt und haben dann Schüsse für einen Ferrari reingepackt. Und wenn du den dann gefunden hast, und du hast auch noch den Ferrari gefunden, dann war er halt deiner und lauter solche Geschichten irgendwie. Mir hat auch letztens jemand erzählt...
Was passiert denn, wenn man einfach ein Euro reinlegt?
Kannst du auch machen, aber wie willst du den gleichwertig tauschen?
Oder höher. Dann vermehrt sich das sozusagen.
Ich hab tatsächlich zusammen mit dem Mr. Stief schon mal überlegt, wie man denn eigentlich mal Bitcoins in einen Geocache reinlegen könnte. Also für mich ist die Verbindung Bitcoin und Geocaching natürlich naheliegend, aber ja.
Indem man dann was da rein tut?
Man müsste halt ein Wallet reinlegen, ein Bitcoin-Wallet.
Also eine Datei?
Genau, mit einem ausgedruckten QR-Code. Den kannst du ja dann über dein Handy, wenn du selber auch einen Bitcoin-Account hast, dann kannst du ja den Bitcoin finden. Kannst den dann scannen. Es wäre dann halt freigestellt, ob jemand sich halt Bitcoins da zieht. Man packt halt, weiß ich nicht mal, einen Bitcoin drauf oder zwei oder ob jemand halt Bitcoins dazu legt. Kann sich ja jeder überlegen.
Ah, verstehe. Also man kriegt dann was überwiesen sozusagen.
Es ist quasi ein Gelbeutel drin. Ein materieller Gelbeutel für eine materielle Währung.
Aber was ist denn nun drin?
Ja, mittlerweile ist meistens einfach nur Müll drin.
Müll?
Ja.
Wie Müll?
Der ist hier jugendfrei, oder? Tampons. Meistens, Gott sei Dank, nicht Gebrauchte.
Also wenn sie nicht...
Kann, kann, also als Frau kann das ja manchmal auch nützlich sein, aber weiß ich nicht, ob man das so einfach nehmen will. Also so Kondomen, die ich in Geocaches finde, würde ich jetzt auch erstmal nicht so vertrauen. Also was ein absolutes No-Go ist, ist Essen, logischerweise. Weil du weißt ja nie, wann das gefunden wird, wenn du da Bonbons reinpackst und die werden feucht oder Seife und die wird feucht. Ich meine, das ist einfach kein Spaß mehr. Kann auch Tiere anlocken. Die machen da natürlich den Cash kaputt. Also Essen sollte man wirklich tun nichts, einfach nicht machen. Lustig sind Erfrischungstücher. Ganz populär waren mal eine Zeit lang Schlüsselbänder. Es gibt auch einen Schlüsselband Cash in Berlin. Der ist auch sehr, sehr liebevoll gemacht. Hat jemand so eine längliche Tupperdose genommen und oben so ein Holzgestell ganz liebevoll reingebaut. Da kannst du dann die Schlüsselbänder quasi anhängen. Und wenn du so Schlüsselband-Fan bist, dann gehst du halt dahin, bringst selber Schlüsselbänder mit und suchst dir eins aus, das dir gut gefällt. Es gibt auch zum Beispiel Post Offices. Es gibt Geocaching-Post. Hier habe ich zum Beispiel mal einen gefunden. Der Cash hatte einen Stempel.
Du hättest jetzt dein Büchlein in der Hand.
Genau.
Was ist das für ein Büchlein?
Das ist mein Geocaching. Also mein Geocaching-Nick ist The Frühtau.
Frühtau. Zu Berge.
Ich habe auch, als ich meinen tausendsten Cash gefunden habe, mir ein lieber Geocaching-Kollege einen Cash gelegt zum tausendsten The Frühtau-Cash. Der heißt natürlich The Frühtau zu Berge. Und dessen Koordinaten liegen genau auf meiner Wohnung. Also ich könnte mir zum Beispiel eine Visitenkarte machen und die GC-Nummer von dem Cash angeben. Wie hat er das gemacht, dass die Koordinaten auf meiner Wohnung liegen? Der Cash selber ist ja nicht bei meiner Wohnung. Was uns mal wieder zurückbringt, übrigens zu mehreren Cash-Typen. Das ist nämlich ein sogenannter Mystery. Ein Mystery-Cash, also Rätsel-Cash. Da musst du zuerst ein Rätsel lösen und aus dem Rätsel ergeben sich dann die Koordinaten. Damit du also ungefähr weißt, wo der Final liegen könnte, deswegen der Final, also die letztendliche Dose, ist die Regel, dass die Fake-Koordinaten sozusagen im Umkreis von drei Kilometern von dem Final liegen müssen. Das heißt, wenn du bei Geocaching nach Caches suchst, kannst du zum Beispiel über ein Google-Map Darstellung machen. Und du siehst da blaue Rätselhaken, blaue Fragezeichen, dann weißt du, aha, im Umkreis von drei Kilometern um den Rätselhaken ist der Cache. Wo genau, das musst du dann über ein Rätsel eben erst erraten.
Und das befindet sich aber dann auch an der Stelle, wo das Fragezeichen ist?
Nein, du musst überhaupt nicht an den Ort gehen in der Regel. Das ist mir auch schon, also ganz dummer Anfängerfehler bei Mysteries, da hieß zum Beispiel ein Cache hieß irgendwas mit 8. Ich weiß es nicht mehr ganz genau. Jedenfalls war im Listing der Hinweis, suche die offensichtliche Zahl und berechne dann wie folgt. Und dann dachte ich halt, naja klar, du sollst da halt hingehen zu den Mystery-Koordinaten, sollst dort die offensichtliche Zahl suchen und damit dann die Koordinaten berechnen, also das Rätsel lösen, um dann zum Final zu kommen. Ich hatte da schon mehrere hundert Caches gefunden und auch schon ein paar Mysteries und bin dann mit einem versierten Geocaching-Kollegen dahin, wir wollten ihn zusammen machen. Wir kamen da an und haben eine Art Turn-Sport-Lost-Plays gefunden. Da standen ganz sauber, ordentlich aufgereiht mehrere Stadionsitze, immer so Zweiersitze zusammen, an so Gestellen. Und genau auf den Koordinaten war der einzige Sitz, der eine Nummer hatte. Die anderen Sitze hatten keine Nummer mehr. Und es hieß halt, suche die offensichtliche Zahl. Da dachten wir, das muss diese Nummer sein. Und die sollte auch laut Distink doppelt da sein. Und die Sitzplatznummer war 33. Deswegen haben wir natürlich mit der 3 gerechnet. Ja, das war aber überhaupt nicht so. Sondern man hätte eben natürlich, wie das bei Mysteries so ist und was wir auch hätten wissen müssen, vorher rechnen. Also die offensichtliche Zahl war eben im Listing versteckt. Und auch, sie war auch hervorgehoben. Also wir hätten es wissen können. Und als wir dann wieder zu Hause waren, fiel da meinem Geocaching-Kollegen ein, ich habe ja schon mal so einen ähnlichen Mystery gelöst, der geht ja so und so, guck mal.
Also Mystery Cache heißt immer, in der Beschreibung selbst ist eigentlich das Rätsel bereits enthalten, was man braucht, um auf eine Koordinate zu kommen.
Genau, also bevor du nicht die Final-Koordinaten final wirklich endgültig hast, indem du das Rätsel gelöst hast, brauchst du gar nicht erst losgehen.
Aber gibt es diese Schatzsuche-Simulation jetzt nicht? Weil das fände ich ja jetzt in gewisser Hinsicht naheliegend, dass man sagt, ich baue hier einen Cache an der Stelle. Und da ist dann sozusagen der erste Hint, der dich zum nächsten Cache bringt, bis du dann halt so schnitzeljagdmäßig irgendwann die Lösung hast und keine Ahnung, vielleicht machst du das irgendwie auch noch klug, dass es dann immer von der Tageszeit oder dem Wochentag abhängig ist und du hast dann sozusagen verschiedenste Verästelungen und kannst an verschiedenen Lösungsorten rauskommen.
Tim, wir müssen meinen Cache zusammenlegen. Also das, was du jetzt ansprichst, das gibt es auch, das ist dann aber kein Mystery, sondern das ist ein Multicache. Und der heißt Multivalue, wenn du eben durch mehrere Stationen durchläufst, bis du zum Final kommst. Genau das, was du gerade beschrieben hast.
Okay, das ist die Schatzung.
Du fängst an am Start und wirst dann durch mehrere Stationen durchgeleitet, musst Rätsel lösen oder findest vor Ort irgendwas oder findest einfach nur irgendwo die nächsten Koordinaten irgendwo hingeschrieben und kämpfst dich dann durch bis zum Final.
Sind das jetzt schon die drei Basistypen so?
Das sind so die gängigsten.
Also diese traditionellen Final-Typen? Also Final und traditionell ist sozusagen dasselbe?
Nee, einen Final findest du immer, das ist immer die Dose. Der Final ist immer die Dose. Beim Tradi eben gleich hin, beim Multi durch mehrere Stationen durch bis zum Final und bei Mystery die Final-Koordinaten errechnen und den Final finden. Es gibt natürlich auch Multi-Mysteries. Da musst du eben quasi die Start-Koordinate errechnen und kommst dann in Multi rein.
Verstehe.
Gibt's auch.
Multi-Cache ist aber nicht so dein Ding.
Ich mach eigentlich alles, was mir so vor die Flinte kommt, sagen wir's mal so. Also nach meinem Tausendsten ist das ein bisschen abgeflaut, aber auch vorher habe ich schon ein bisschen weniger gecached, weil ich sehr viel gearbeitet habe und dann nicht mehr so viel Zeit hatte. Und mittlerweile ist für mich eigentlich, also ganz am Anfang fand ich es, nach diesem ersten langweiligen Sonntag mit dem Sohn, habe ich dann überall Geocaches gesucht. Ich war auf dem Weg zur Arbeit, Geocaches mitgenommen, auf dem Weg nach Hause Geocaches mitgenommen. Die Homezone sauber halten ist auch immer so eine schöne Aufgabe, also quasi so einen gewissen Umkreis von drei bis fünf Kilometern um den eigenen Wohnort sozusagen alle Caches gefunden zu haben. Das ist natürlich auch immer schön. Dann werden auch immer welche archiviert, dann kommen wieder neue raus. Also hat man sozusagen auch immer zu tun. Eigentlich sollte man so, weiß ich nicht, vielleicht alle zwei, drei Jahre mal umziehen, damit man wieder eine neue Homezone hat zum sauber machen oder so. Genau. Mittlerweile ist es für mich eher so, ich suche mir gerne schöne Caches raus, ich mag gern Kletter-Caches, ich mag gern Caches in Lost Places, wo man teilweise auch ganz schön rumklettern muss. Im Moment finde ich Baumklettern super cool. Es gibt viele Geocaches, die auf Bäumen liegen. Das ist eine sehr schöne Sache, finde ich auch vor allem ein sehr schöner Ausgleichssport zu dieser Computer-Hockerei, weil du beim Klettern den ganzen Körper auch einfach brauchst und dann merkst du auch mal wieder, du hast einen Rücken. Gibt's? Gibt's? Genau, Rücken findet statt.
Ich wollte noch mal kurz diese, wir waren ja im Prinzip dabei, so diese Eigenschaften von den Caches mal so ein bisschen zusammenzutragen, damit man auch weiß, wie man das beschreibt bzw. dekodiert, wenn man das jetzt so vorfindet. Wir können gleich noch mal ein bisschen auf Cache-Suche gehen. Also es gibt diesen Cache-Typ. Traditioneller Cache, okay, also der sozusagen nur ein Final Cache ist, also das, was ich finde und dann eben verschiedene Arten da hinzukommen. Entweder dieser Mystery-Cache, ich muss einen Rätsel lösen, dann bin ich da. Multi-Cache, die sind irgendwie miteinander versequenziert, so einer nach dem anderen. Oder Multi-Mystery mit Rätsel, Spaß und Schatzsuche in einem. Genau. Und das ist sozusagen erstmal so, dass man schonmal weiß, worauf man sich eigentlich einlässt. Und dann, damit man auch weiß, worauf man sich einlässt, dieses Wo ist es und wie schwierig ist es. Jetzt waren wir ja vorhin schon kurz bei diesem Wo ist es, aber sind ja so richtig vom Bürgersteig nicht so richtig weggekommen. Vielleicht so bis zur Wiese nebenan, so 1,5.
Wir sind schon auf dem Baum geklettert?
Ja genau, aber wie muss man jetzt diese Zahl, wie würdest du jetzt, also was wäre eine 2? Wenn 1 einfach nur auf the beaten path ist, so was wäre eine 2?
Ja, also zwischen 2 und 4, da wird es halt tatsächlich, finde ich persönlich, schwierig. Also wenn ich zum Beispiel einen T4er-Cache mache und ich suche den, dann suche ich natürlich aufgrund der T-Wertungen an bestimmten Orten und andere lasse ich schon von vornherein weg, weil die einfach dieser T-Wertung nicht entsprechen. Also ich brauche nicht auf dem Gehsteig stehen und erwarten, dass ich den Cache finde beim T4. Das ist natürlich Quatsch. Also da denke ich mir schon, okay, ich muss vielleicht auch mal irgendwo hochklettern, ich muss irgendwo dahinter gucken oder runterklettern. Also es gab zum Beispiel mal einen Cache-Owner, der hat immer Geocaches in irgendwelche, weiß ich nicht, Bunkerkanalisationen auf irgendwelche Bäume. Es war immer irgendwo oben oder irgendwo unten. Auch Tradis, aber immer irgendwo oben, irgendwo unten. Und der hat in sein Listing nur noch reingeschrieben, klare Aufgabe. Und das wusste man einfach, wenn man von dem was sucht, ne, T4er, klare Aufgabe, okay, ich komm dahin, ich muss runter oder ich muss hoch. So, klares Ding. Ja, und irgendwo so zwischen zwei und drei, das ist halt auch immer so ein bisschen dann Einschätzung, was da alles so an Faktoren zusammenfällt, wie der Owner das dann sieht. Der eine sagt, das ist ein Zweier, der nächste sagt, naja, das ist eigentlich schon eher ein Dreier. Dann einigt man sich vielleicht auf zweieinhalb.
Mit anderen Worten, das ist doch so wie bei den fünf Sternen. Jeder weiß, was ein Stern, jeder weiß, was fünf Sterne heißen. Alles dazwischen ist irgendwie unklar.
Ja, genau. Aber du brauchst eine, also du brauchst irgendeine Form von Skalierung dazwischen. Also anders zum Beispiel bei der Bewertung. Da gibt es zum Beispiel zwei verschiedene Systeme, sehr lange gab es das sogenannte GC-Vote, Geocaching-Vote. Das war eine Browser-Extension. Ich glaube so ein Firefox, Grease, Monkey, JavaScript-Ding oder so. Da konntest du halt für jeden Cache auch eins bis fünf Sterne vergeben, auch mit Halbstufen dazwischen. Und das ist ziemlich schnell sehr in die Kritik geraten, weil Cache-Owner zum Beispiel gesagt haben, ich finde das eine Unverschämtheit, dass mein Cache mit nur einem Stern bewertet wird, weil immerhin habe ich mir ja die Mühe gemacht, einen Cache überhaupt hinzulegen. Und ihr seid ja gekommen und habt ihn ja auch gefunden.
Also die Sterne sollten jetzt schon aussagen, er ist gut oder nicht so gut. Spannend oder nicht spannend.
Und da ist natürlich klar, alles, was unter drei Sternen ist, ist ja eigentlich doof.
Sterne funktionieren nicht. Das ist eine alte Weisheit. YouTube hat das verstanden und haben irgendwie das auf dieses einfache Daumen hoch, Daumen runter Modell. Facebook das auch mit dem Daumen runter? Ich glaube, dass Menschen grundsätzlich nur in der Lage sind, so eine einfache binäre Entscheidung zu fällen, ob etwas irgendwie ist oder nicht ist. Aber wenn du sie fragst, wie ist es von eins bis fünf, dann geht es einfach nicht. Das heißt, wenn du sagst, hat dir gefallen oder hat dir nicht gefallen, dann kommt nicht so etwas wie zwei Sterne bei raus, was irgendwie nämlich nichts aussagt.
Naja, es sagt zumindest schon mal, ist doof. Also eins ist dann einfach, ist doof. Fünf ist super cool und eins ist halt, ist doof.
Ja, aber vielleicht meinten die Leute das auch gar nicht so richtig. Also was ist denn drei Sterne? Ist das jetzt gut oder schlecht? Ich bin indifferent, ich kann mich nicht entscheiden. Wenn du aber klar sagst, war das jetzt gut oder nicht gut, dann würden, glaube ich, die Leute mit den drei Sternen einfach nichts sagen.
Ja, nein, vielleicht.
Oder sich dann vielleicht doch eher auf, na so schlecht war es eigentlich gerade nicht. Eigentlich war es okay.
Ja, GroundSpeak hat ja dann, ich glaube, vor zwei oder drei Jahren kam das irgendwie ein eigenes Bewertungssystem eingeführt. Das sind die sogenannten Fuff Points. So blaue Schleifen, da habe ich dir hier auch mal so ein Travel-Bank mitgebracht. Das ist hier so ein Fuff Point zum Beispiel.
Oh, The Real Favorite Point for Travel steht hier drauf.
Das ist also ein sogenannter Reisender. Also es gibt zwei Sorten Gadgets, die in...
Warte mal, ich muss noch kurz beschreiben, was hier in... Also es ist ein Stück durchscheinendes blaues Plastik, halt in dieser... Wie heißen denn diese Dinger? Also so ein bisschen so Blume mit zwei Schleifchen dran, so, ne? Diese Dinger, die Amerikaner mal tragen auf irgendwelchen...
Eher ein Medaillen auszeichnen.
Ja, also nicht wirklich eine Medaille, mehr so ein Badge, keine Ahnung. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob das nett... Kommen wir vielleicht noch drauf. So, und das als Plastik-Anhänger sozusagen.
Genau.
Und das drückt jetzt was aus, dieses Teil? Das ist ein Account, oder was?
Das ist ein Travel-Bug. Ein Travel... Ein Reisender sozusagen. Genau, ein Travel-Bug. Das ist ein Gegenstand, an dem... Der hat eben auch so eine Nummer. Das ist so eine Tracking-Nummer. Die darfst du nicht vorlesen.
Ja, hab ich nicht getan. Sehr gut.
Buchstaben, Zahlen, genau. Und mit dieser Nummer kann man... Also, die könntest du jetzt zum Beispiel eingeben und könntest sagen, ich hab diesen Travel-Bug bei The Frühtower gesehen, als wir den Chaosradio Express zum Thema Geocaching aufgenommen haben. Zum Beispiel. Und dieser Travel-Bug hat dann ähnlich wie ein Geocache auch so eine eigene Seite. Da erscheint das dann als Log. Und der kann dann... Also, die Idee von Travel-Bugs ist, dass die von Cache zu Cache reisen. Also, ich hab den in einem Cache gefunden, in Thüringen, im Örtelsbruch. Das ist so ein aufgelassener Schiefer, Schieferabbau. Aufgelassene Schieferabbaugelände. Da findet übrigens wirklich Geocaching-Tourismus statt. Also, wir kamen dahin, wollten den Cache machen. Wir waren zu fünft, haben uns das Wochenende schon lange vorher freigehalten. Kamen zu fünft dahin, zu den Parkplatzkoordinaten wollten los und als wir da auf den Parkplatz ankamen, da standen schon mal sechs Autos. Alles Geocacher waren da unterwegs. Und das ist also der Hausmeister vom Örtelsbruch. Er ist auch ein hoch mit Pfaffpunkten dekorierter Cash. Also muss man mal gemacht haben. Da habe ich diesen Travel Bug drin gefunden. Den habe ich jetzt mitgenommen. Und den kann ich jetzt in den nächsten Cash wieder ablegen. Und das wird halt dokumentiert. Und das kannst du auf der Seite von diesem Travel Bug sehen. Deswegen Reisender. Also kannst du dann sehen, wo der schon überall lang gereist ist.
Okay, also es repräsentiert nicht jetzt irgendjemand, sondern es ist einfach nur ein Ding, was von Cash zu Cash reist und was dann so quasi getrackt durch die Webseite irgendwann so einen langen Lauf quer über den Planeten macht. Genau. Du hast den jetzt gerade, aber du wirst den demnächst wieder irgendwo reinstopfen, wo du es für angemessen hältst. Und dann nimmst du aber wahrscheinlich auch eher so einen von den tolleren Caches dafür, oder?
Ja, in dem Fall auf jeden Fall. Das ist ja ein Pfaffpunkt. Also der hat ja, da hängt ja so ein Zettelchen dran, so ein gelbes. Und da steht ja seine Mission drauf. Ich glaube, auf einer Seite auf Deutsch, auf einer Seite auf Englisch.
Ah, soll ich das vorlesen?
Ja.
Ich bin der blaue Favoritenpunkt und möchte gerne Caches besuchen, die einen extra Punkt verdienen. Das heißt, der Cache verdient dadurch einen Punkt, dadurch, dass man den da ablegt?
Nein. Sondern? Der Wunsch ist, dass da, wo ich so einen Favoritenpunkt vergeben würde für einen Cache...
Da solltest du das Teil reinschmeißen?
Ich den auch da wieder reinlegen. Genau.
Aber ist es nicht so, dass der Cache selber eine Aufwertung erhält, dadurch, dass man da einen Bug reintut? Außer, dass er halt eine Linie dann verbunden ist.
Aber die Idee ist ja natürlich, denke ich mal, von dem Owner, von dem Travel Bug. Der möchte dann halt mal gucken, wo war denn der überall? Aha, das sind also alles Caches, die Leute gut fanden und für diesen Favoritenpunkt vergeben haben. Das ist ja auch clever. Also ich mag ja zum Beispiel gerne Lost Places. Und ich habe mir hier so eine Coin geholt von einem Lost Place Event. Lost in MV, Lost in Mecklenburg. Das war hier 2011. Und da gibt es hier so eine Geocoin. Das ist die zweite Form der Reisenden. Also du siehst den Unterschied, wie du es in der Hand hältst. Das ist mehr so eine Münze. Auch mit so einer Tracking-Nummer. Und das ist deswegen halt eine Geocoin. Im Gegensatz zum Travel Bug. Der Travel Bug ist ein Gegenstand an denen, die normalerweise immer wie so ein Dog-Tag dran gehängt ist. Du kannst ja deinen Lieblingsteady-Bear nehmen, hängst so ein Dog-Tag dran und sagst halt auch, mein Lieblingsteady-Bear will kuschelige Plätze in der Welt sehen. Macht mal schöne Fotos.
So wie bei Amelie.
Ja, ja.
War das ein Teddy-Bear? Was war das nochmal? So ein Stofftierchen machte so seine Reisen.
Für den Vater, ne? Glaub ich. Ich hab noch mehr Coins. Ich hab halt eine von diesen Lost-in-MV-Coins, zwei davon hab ich losgeschickt. Und hab denen die Mission gegeben, Besuche Lost Places. Das heißt, ich kann da jetzt auf die Seite gucken, kann gucken, wo die überall waren. Und wenn ich da jetzt plane, auch mal da in der Gegend zu sein, dann kann ich mal gucken, gibt's da vielleicht ein Lost Place, wo mein Coin war.
Aber das kannst nur du sehen.
Nee, das kann alle sehen, die den tracken.
Aber alle, die den Code kennen, sozusagen.
Genau, und der Trick ist eben...
Es gibt kein Verzeichnis von diesen ganzen Coins und so, sondern man muss schon in etwa wissen.
Also, es gibt natürlich Sammler von diesen Coins.
Die sie nicht rausrücken.
Genau. Und es gibt ja auch seltene Stücke. Zum Beispiel der Coin, den ich dir gegeben hab, hier von der Cebit, Jeremy Irish, davon. Das ist eine Sonderedition. Davon gibt es, glaube ich, 12 oder 15 Coins nur. Mehr wurden davon nicht hergestellt. Das war eine Coin, die geprägt wurde aus Anlass des Besuches von Jeremy Irish auf der Cebit.
Das muss man mal kurz sagen, wer Jeremy Irish ist.
Genau. Jeremy Irish ist der Gründer von Geocaching oder einer der Gründer, also die Hauptfigur. Und zwar kam der zu Cebit anlässlich 10 Jahre Geocaching. Das war, glaube ich, 2011. Das steht, glaube ich, auf der Coin drauf, wenn ich mich richtig entsinne. Lustig.
Einfach nur Cebit.
So, ich gucke mal eben nach. 2011 war es. März 2011, genau.
Das heißt, hier ist mir die Coin selber das Andenken an sich, dass die würdest du jetzt nicht wirklich weiter reichen wollen, weil...
Naja, also wenn ich die jetzt auf Reise schicken würde, dann würde sie wahrscheinlich ziemlich schnell verschwinden, und zwar entweder in der Hand irgendeines Sammlers. Oder es gibt ja eben auch... Also es gibt ja Geocacher und Muggels. Muggels kennt man von Harry Potter. Das sind ja die uneingeweihten, die Blöden. Also diese normalen Menschen, die halt nicht wissen, was Geocaches sind. Und die machen da manchmal Geocaches kaputt. Entweder unbedacht. Oder sie sehen, da kommen immer wieder Leute hin, die suchen da irgendwas. Dann gehen sie da auch hin und gucken mal, was die da wohl suchen. Dann finden sie da eben eine Filmdose oder eine Dose. Und da sind dann vielleicht auch solche Coins drin. Dann nehmen sie die mit. Und wenn sie ganz ausgefuchst sind, dann haben sie sogar einen Account auf Geocaching, einen kostenfreien. Und finden dann auch den Cash, den sie da gemuggelt haben, zerstört haben. Und schreiben dann vielleicht auch noch so eine Note hin. Ja, hier übrigens, ich hab den Cash jetzt endlich gefunden und ich hab ihn kaputt gemacht und die geht bloß keine mehr hin und so. Es gibt auch Leute, die zerstören Geocaches.
Naja, ich mein, das ist ja der Lauf der Dinge. Das ist ja dann auch wieder das Abbild der Gesellschaft. Man muss auch mit Zerstörungen und Kulturpessimisten leben. Naja, durch Destruktion entsteht ja auch wieder Neues.
Ja, es gibt aber auch welche, die räubern einfach nur Coins aus. Die sehen dann, ah, hier ist eine Dose bei mir in der Nähe. Da sind immer wieder schöne Coins drin. Ich geh einfach immer wieder hin und räum die einfach alle ab. Davon kriegst du erstmal gar nichts mit. Und als Cash-Owner kriegst du dann vielleicht, nachdem die das schon vier, fünf Mal gemacht haben, zum ersten Mal eine Nachricht vom Coin-Owner oder von anderen Geocachern. Hier sind übrigens keine Coins mehr drin. Das passiert dir dann drei, vier Mal. Und dann schreibst du natürlich ins Listing auch rein. Hört mal, Leute, liegt hier mal keine Coins mehr ab, weil die verschwinden garantiert.
Ich versuche gerade dieses Geocoin, also das mit den Bugs, das habe ich jetzt, glaube ich, verstanden. Das ist sozusagen wirklich zum Auf die Reise geben und soll reisen. Aber was jetzt der Unterschied zur Geocoin in dem Sinne ist, die ja eigentlich auch reisen soll, ist mir noch nicht so hundertprozentig klar geworden.
Also die Coin ist eben tatsächlich eine Coin. Also das ist ein Stück zum Beispiel. Ein Coin hat nie so einen Anhänger dran, wie der Travel Bug zum Beispiel. Und die Nummer ist auch eingestanzt. Beim Travel Bug ist eigentlich, also der, den du da hast, ist so ein Zwischending zwischen Travel Bug und Coin, weil die Nummer steht ja drauf, aber das ist ja auch keine Coin, weil es ja so ein Plastik-Ding ist. Der Travel Bug hat normalerweise immer so ein kleines Metallplättchen dran, so ein Dog-Tag eben, was so Hunde manchmal am Halsband haben, wo da eine Nummer drauf steht. Oder falls sie diesen Hund finden, rufen sie ihn, blablabla. Und da steht dann die Tracking-Nummer drauf. Und der Unterschied ist sozusagen, eine Coin ist eben dieser Gegenstand, der so eine Münzform hat. Also ich habe hier zum Beispiel noch so einen Drachen-Coin. Hier haben wir einen Nacht-Cash-Coin. Und die hat so funkelnde Augen, selbstleuchtende Augen an der Nacht. Kannst du das sehen?
So.
Oder hier zum Beispiel. Das ist eine Coin, die habe ich geschenkt bekommen, wenn ich mal in Wartburg hatte.
Aber das ist doch ein Trabi.
Ja, aber in Wartburg gibt es leider nicht als Coin. Deswegen habe ich ein Trabi bekommen. Weil ich eben in den Wartburg habe ich öfter drei, vier Geocacher reingeladen. Wir sind dann mal auf Landpartie gefahren. Von einer Freundin, die öfter mitgefahren ist, habe ich diese Coin geschenkt bekommen.
Sehr hübsch. Mit dem Code als Nummernschild und das trackable at geocaching.com, was hier immer so draufsteht. Schön im Trabant-Design. Das Trackable. Ich meine, so hübsch wie die Dinger sind, da hat man das Gefühl, dass die nie groß auf Reisen gehen können. Also die kauft man, um sie nicht zu benutzen, oder?
Ja, das ist unterschiedlich. Also es gibt da natürlich auch Limited Editions und so ein Zeug. Also ich hab zum Beispiel, als ich meinen 1000. Cash gefunden hab, da wurde ich wie jeder anständige Pfingstoxe dann entsprechend behängt. Von meinen Geocaching Kumpels. Und zwar hier, ne?
Schön Runde Marke hier. 1000 Caches. 1000 Caches gefunden. Da ist halt der Award.
Genau. Die gibt's schon für 100, für 200, für 500, für 1000. Der nächste wäre jetzt 2000. Danach gibt's dann 5000. Leute, die haben schon über 10.000 gefunden. Ist auch eine Coin eben.
Ja, aber wo kriegt man denn diese Nummer her? Kriegt man die sich auf geocaching.com?
Nee, da, wo man die Coin bestellt. Die kümmern sich darum, dass es die Nummer gibt. Und dann musst du das Ding auch noch mal aktivieren. Also der ist jetzt nicht aktiviert, der ist sozusagen bei mir. Der andere zum Beispiel, der mit dem Drachen, den du hast, oder dieser blaue Fuffpoint, die sind aktiviert, die sind auf Reisen, die gehen dann los. Oder hier, schau mal, zum Beispiel, hab ich zum...
Und wer macht dann die Registry dafür? Also ich mein, das muss ja dann trotzdem ein Unique Code sein, also letztlich...
Das macht GroundSpeak.
Also Geocaching sozusagen, da ist ja diese Geocoin-Produktion gehört ja quasi dazu.
Genau, also wenn jemand diese Coins produziert, da gibt's zum Beispiel hier, Sepp und Berta machen das, unter mygeocoin.de, sie ist Grafikerin und hat irgendwann angefangen, Geocoins zu machen, die sind sehr begehrt, die kommen dann auch manchmal in limitierter Edition raus und so weiter. Wenn du also da jetzt verrückt genug bist, dann, hier gibt's zum Beispiel eine vom Oktoberfest, die sitzen da in München. Also wenn du da eine Idee hast eben für so ein Coin, dann sprichst du halt mit ihr das Design ab und sagst halt, in welcher Form die rauskommen soll, also welche Überzüge, ob da Relief drauf sein soll und nicht, oder nicht und so weiter und so weiter. Und sagst dann, in welcher Limitierung das rauskommen soll. Da hast du zum Beispiel diese Award-Dinger.
Genau.
Und gibst die dann bei ihren Auftrag und kannst die dann über den Shop bei ihr verkaufen. Ich glaube, so ungefähr funktioniert das.
Ich verkaufe die dann sozusagen über den Laden. Die produzieren das und dann kriegt man auch noch Geld dafür sozusagen.
Genau. Und wenn es halt dann eine sehr schöne Coin ist, die halt in einer kleinen Auflage rauskommt, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du die in freier Wildbahn findest, natürlich sehr gering.
Ja, aber wenn man sagt, ihr könnt so viele kaufen, wie ihr wollt, muss man das dann irgendwie selber vorfinanzieren?
Das macht ja nicht Sie, ne, also die machen sozusagen, wenn sie selber natürlich eine Idee haben und wollen das machen, dann machen sie das natürlich und verkaufen das so weiter.
Aber ich kann ja auch einen Design hinschicken und sagen, hier so in etwa dann wird das sozusagen konkretisiert und als konkrete Coin-Vorlage dann hergestellt und dann umgesetzt.
Genau.
Was man mit der Umsetzung nichts mehr zu tun hat.
So sieht's aus. Und dabei werden natürlich dann auch die trackable Nummern von GC ja halt eben bestellt, weil die müssen ja in die Münze eingraviert werden.
Ja.
Und so wird das dann quasi verwaltet.
Und diese Nummern kosten dann auch nochmal Geld oder wie?
Ja, das läuft aber mit in der Produktion sozusagen.
Aber das ist dann sozusagen auch nochmal so ein Einnahmemodell für die eigentliche Plattform selber auch.
Ja. Also bei Sepp und Bertha gingen dann natürlich ganz, ganz viele Wünsche immer ein und könnte dann mal so eine Coin und so eine Coin und dann rief halt irgendwann jeder an und wollte mal so seine eigene Coin mal irgendwie so haben. Und deswegen, wenn du hier mal links unten guckst, die seine, deine Geocoin, haben die jetzt was gemacht, da kannst du für 12 Euro, kannst du einfach da ein Bild hochladen und kannst dann deine eigene Coin, oder 14 Euro sind es mittlerweile, genau, kannst dann deine eigene Coin rausbringen.
Und für was werden die so in der Regel verkauft? Also, was muss man hier so investieren?
Na, diese, die du dir hier konfigurieren kannst, ist ja dann 14 Euro pro Stück. Du kannst ja eine für 14 Euro machen, du kannst ja auch 50 für 14 Euro machen. Das ist dann egal, finde ich, finde ich sehr clever, sehr schön auch. Und bei den anderen, die halt so diese Spezialanfertigungen sind, da kommt es halt immer ein bisschen drauf an, wie hochwertig die gemacht sind, wie teuer die Prägung ist, die Farben und so weiter. Also ob das quasi so eine Relief-Coin ist oder ob das so ein flaches Ding ist, wo einfach nur was reingraviert wurde oder so.
Aber es kann jetzt richtig teuer werden, oder nur um so eine Größenordnung und was?
Ja, also ich würde sagen, ein normaler Coin-Preis ist sowas um so 10, 15 Euro irgendwie. Du kannst aber auch mal 40 oder 60 Euro für eine Coin zahlen. Und es gibt bestimmt auch schon Coins für, weiß ich nicht, 2000 Euro mit Diamanten drin oder keine Ahnung, also es gibt ja auch iPhones mit Diamanten und keine Ahnung, ich weiß ja nicht, es können sich alles mögliche ausdenken, denke ich mal.
Okay, das heißt, es gibt, sagen wir mal so, Coins, die man eigentlich herstellen lässt, so um Unikate zu sein, die eigentlich nie wirklich dafür gedacht sind, mal wirklich aktiviert und durch Dosen geschleppt zu werden. Aber dann gibt es auch, sagen wir mal so, à la velle Coins, die irgendwie immer noch schick aussehen, aber die jetzt wirklich dazu da sind, mal in so einen Cash gelegt zu werden, um dann auch auf Reisen zu gehen.
Genau.
Da unterscheidet sich jetzt aber auch nicht so viel von diesen Travel-Bugs.
Nee, das Prinzip ist das Gleiche, nur dass die Bugs halt keine Coins sind.
Okay, gut. Also es gibt sozusagen so zwei Ausprägungen des selben Dings, dieses Etwas ist dafür gemacht, von Cash zu Cash zu wandern.
Man nennt die Reisende. Also wenn jemand sagt, hier hast du ein paar Reisende, ja was hast du denn, ja ein paar Travel-Bugs oder paar Coins.
Verstehe, das ist sozusagen die Klassifizierung an der Stelle. Jetzt hab ich es glaube ich langsam verstanden.
Ja, guck mal, hier habe ich noch einen bekommen zu meinem 40. Geburtstag.
Ach. Wie kann ich denn jetzt auf die Spur kommen? Hier mit der tollen Plattform.
Auf geocaching.com? Du hast dich ja hier auch gerade angelegt als Basic-Member. Genau, da gehst du mal auf deinen Namen, der ist ja unterstrichen da oben. Tim Pritlove. Tim ist Tim Pritlove auf geocaching.com übrigens jetzt. Da siehst du jetzt hier diese ganzen Links. Da steht auch your friends.
Ah, ich kann Freunde machen.
Genau, your friends. Und da tippst du jetzt mal ein The Frühtau. Ja, genau, mit Umlaut. geocaching.com macht mit Umlaut.
Sehr schön.
Und jetzt siehst du hier contacting The Frühtau. Da gehst du auf View Profile. Und da siehst du hier auch mein Logo. Das hat übrigens auch hier Sepp und Bertha gemacht. The Frühtau, dieses Logo. Weil ich wollte nämlich mal einen Stempel haben hier. Guck, ich hab so einen Geocaching-Stempel. Und wenn ich an den Cache komme und das Logbuch ist groß genug, dann kann ich ja meinen Stempel reindrücken.
Du kannst den Caches sozusagen deinen Stempel aufdrücken.
Genau. Und dann gibt es halt sogenannte Letterbox Caches. Das ist zum Beispiel das, was ich dir vorhin gezeigt hatte in meinem Büchlein. Dieses Stempel hier. Geo Post Office Dessau. Letterboxes sind halt Caches, wo der Cache einen Stempel hat. Und die darfst du eigentlich auch nur loggen, wenn du selbst auch stempelst. Also alles abgestempelt. Ich habe gerade versucht zu sagen, das ist Deutschland hier, aber die gibt es ja auch in Amerika. Oder hier zum Beispiel. Da gab es einen am alten Flugfeld.
Das heißt, du stempelst überall, wo so ein Heft in so einem Cache liegt, da hinterlässt du dann dein Stempelzettel.
Wenn das Logbuch groß genug ist. Wenn das Logbuch klein ist, dann finde ich es ein bisschen unverschämt, sozusagen da so viel Platz im Logbuch einzunehmen.
Du könntest ja noch so einen kleinen Stempel machen.
Genau, manche haben extra auch so ein Mikrostempel, aber das wollte ich nicht.
Aber das ist ja fancy hier, so ein kleiner Club-Pocketstamp. Sehr fancy, so in der Größe eines UMTS Modems.
So 35 Millimeter Durchmesser hat der schon.
Ja, so ein bisschen Plastik zieht man auseinander und dann klappt sich hier so ein ziemlich fetter Stempel aus. Richtig mit Stempelkissen und Pipapo. Das ist ja fancy.
Ja, Geocaching ist natürlich auch immer irgendwie Gadget-Porn, ist klar.
Ja, ich nähere mich dem langsam an.
Ich habe auch noch mehr Gadgets mitgebracht.
Der Tisch ist voll.
So ist das auch bei Geocaching-Stammtischen übrigens, ne? Die kommen dann alle, die haben dann... Die haben manchmal wirklich...
Na so, zeigst du mir deins, zeige ich dir meins.
Nee, also, als ich zum ersten Geocaching-Stammtisch gegangen bin, da sah ich lauter Menschen, die hatten Stapel an Papiere dabei. Ausgedruckte Cash-Listings. Und die haben sich dann getroffen. Das war so mein erster Eindruck von der Geocaching-Community, da hatte ich so 50 Cashes gefunden oder so. Die haben sich dann getroffen und haben dann gesagt, hier guck mal, ich hab hier paar Cashes, da bin ich nicht so richtig weitergekommen. Hast du davon schon welche gefunden? Damit man sich Hints geben kann. Und dann sagen die, ja, gib mir mal deinen Papierstapel, guck mal, hier ist mein Papierstapel, das sind meine, die ich noch nicht hab. Hast du davon schon welche? Und dann gucken sie das Papierstapel durch. Dann sagt der z.B., wieso hast du schon alles gefunden? Warum kommst du nicht auf die Lösung? Also man sagt dann in der Regel auch vorher, ja, gib mir mal die Final-Koordinaten. Also bei mir kommt sowas immer nicht gut an. Ich sag immer, die Final-Koordinaten gebe ich nicht her. Also ich kann dir einen Tipp geben, wenn du mir sagst, wie weit du schon gekommen bist oder wo du hängst oder wo du schon überall geguckt hast oder wie weit du das Rätsel schon gelöst hast. Dann kann ich vielleicht sowas sagen wie, eigentlich fehlt dir nicht mehr viel. Oder, ich weiß, du hast auch den und den Cash gemacht, da ging das genauso. Also so vorsichtig hin, stupsen sozusagen. Und ich mach's selten, dass ich Leuten dann einfach sage, ja dann guck halt da und da oder das Ding ist da und da. Manche betreiben das so. Also es gab zum Beispiel mal einen...
So Beschäftigungstheater.
Nee, nee, das ist eine ganz ernsthafte Geschichte. Also jetzt, das ist wirklich, da darf man sich auch nicht drüber lustig machen. Es gibt ja zum Beispiel sogenannte FTF-er. FTF steht für First to Find. Das sind also Leute, die gucken immer, wann kommt ein neuer Geocache raus, und dann fahren die los und müssen ihn sofort als erstes finden. Die haben dann auch auf ihren Profilen Listen von FTFs, die die gemacht haben. Nee, viel ernsthafter, viel ernsthafter. Weil es geht ja um Statistik und man ist ja auch ein harter Hund. Also ich meine, du hörst an meiner Beschreibung schon. Ich persönlich finde das Pippi Facts. Aber es gibt Leute, die das ernst nehmen.
Es gibt auch Leute, die müssen immer die ersten in der Reihe sein, wenn ein neues iPhone kommt und so.
In die Richtung geht das, genau. Und das war auch an einem meiner ersten Stammtische. Da habe ich einen Casher kennengelernt. Der hatte gerade einen Cash veröffentlicht. Ein D5er Mystery. T-Wert weiß ich gerade nicht mehr. Lost in Space heißt der.
Also D5, Difficulty 5, 5 Sterne. Das heißt, da muss man sich schon vom Gebäude abseilen.
Nee, D5, nicht T5. Die Schwierigkeit.
Ist doch schwierig.
Das ist Terrain, was du meinst, vom Gebäude abseilen.
Ach so, okay. Also Difficulty bezieht sich dann auf, wie schwierig das Finden selbst ist.
In dem Fall, wie schwierig das Rätsel ist. Ah, der Cash selber ist gar nicht. Genau.
Okay, aber so beim normalen Tradi Cash, wenn der jetzt D5 hat, was heißt das?
Der ist super gut getarnt.
Mit Tarnfarbe irgendwie im Busch.
Zum Beispiel, genau. Es gibt auch so Spezies, die gerne kleine braune Nanos im Wald verstecken, packen die halt in den Baum rein. Kiefer zum Beispiel, der ist ja auch braun. Und der Hint, also es gibt im Disting immer einen Hint, der ist Rot 13 encrypted, damit du die nicht aus Versehen lesen kannst, aber du kannst sie dann auch decrypten, wenn du halt dann zum Hint greifen willst.
Also Rot 13, die klassische Internet-Kryptographie, in dem man einfach mal die Buchstaben 13 Zeichen verschiebt.
Genau. Und der schreibt dann halt als Hint zu seinen Caches auch braun. Und dann stehst du halt da im Wald, die Koordinaten sind vielleicht nicht so genau.
Gib mir noch mal einen zweiten Tipp. Ja, grün.
Ah, okay, danke. Du musst dann halt so ein daumennagelgroßes, braunes Ding suchen, das ist halt in einer braunen Rinde steckt, in einem, weiß ich nicht, vielleicht Holzhaufen, wo irgendwie fünfzehn dickere Ästchen übereinander liegen und die sind alle braun und so. Da helfen ja auch genaue Koordinaten nicht mehr, ne?
Lost in Rindenmulch.
Und dieser Cacher, der hat halt diesen Lost in Space gemacht und der hatte diese Idee, dass er sagte, ich, also wenn du so einen Cache legst, du legst den, dann schreibst du das Listing und dann geht er durch einen Review-Prozess. Die Reviewer, die da arbeiten, die machen das ehrenamtlich für GroundSpeak. Und je nachdem, wie viel Caches irgendwo veröffentlicht werden, gibt es halt für eine Region mehr oder weniger Reviewer. Die denken halt ein mehr oder weniger großes Gebiet ab.
Was reviewen die jetzt?
Die gucken sich erstmal das Listing an, ob alles richtig eingetragen ist, ob ein D-Wert und ein T-Wert angegeben ist, wo die Koordinaten sind, dass das Listing gut beschrieben ist. Da gibt es hier noch diese, bei einem Cache gibt es diese Attribute noch dabei. Kannst du angeben, ist der Rollstuhl tauglich, gibt es einen Parkplatz in der Nähe.
Ich bin gerade noch mal ein bisschen begriffverwirrt. Wenn du sagst Listing, was meinst du damit genau?
Das ist die Seite, die ein Geocache im Netz hat, wo der Cache beschrieben ist.
Also die Beschreibung eines Caches, nicht eine Liste von Caches.
Das wäre eine Bookmark-Liste.
Also wenn du sagst Listing, meinst du die Beschreibung eines Caches. Genau, genau das.
Und wir gucken halt, ob alles in Ordnung ist soweit. Und wir gucken auch, ob zum Beispiel Abstandsregeln eingehalten wurden. Abstandsregeln betreffen Abstände zum Beispiel zu Bahnschienen. Nicht so prickelnd, ein Geocache direkt unter die Bahnschiene zu legen. So wie immer in den Steinen rum, vielleicht findest du die Dose ja. Kannst du auch so einen kleinen braun-nano-Hint braun, toll. Ja, nicht so dolle. Also sowas gucken die zum Beispiel an. Oder können sie aufgrund der Koordinaten sehen, dass das Ding vielleicht auf Privatbesitz liegt, wo eigentlich nichts hin sollte und so weiter.
Was geschieht dann?
Dann wird das Ding nicht veröffentlicht.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt einen neuen Cache anlege, dann muss der überhaupt erst mal reviewt werden, bevor der überhaupt das Licht des Tages sieht.
So sieht's aus.
Und das ist dann wiederum die Aufgabe für diese First Post. Wie heißt das noch gleich?
Nee, das machen die Reviewer. Die Reviewer checken halt, dass er sozusagen formal in Ordnung ist.
Okay, dazu braucht man aber einen Sonderstatus, dass man überhaupt erst mal Listings sieht, die noch eigentlich gar nicht veröffentlicht sind.
Genau.
Weil du es nicht sein willst oder weil du die Würden nie verdienen bekommen hast?
Es reizt mich irgendwie nicht.
Okay, aber muss man sich da irgendwie qualifizieren, anmelden, bewerben, gewählt werden? Wie wird man Reviewer?
Ja, also ich glaube, man wird Reviewer, indem man Reviewer kennt. Und wenn die halt hören, dass irgendwo einer aufhört oder dass irgendwo einer mehr gebraucht wird, dann wird man da irgendwie ins Gespräch gebracht. Also ich weiß zum Beispiel, in Graz vor fünf oder sechs Jahren erzählte mir ein Geocaching-Kollege, dass es da halt ganz schlimm ist, weil da gab es nur einen Reviewer und der hat halt sehr nach eigenem Gusto, die das jetzt zugelassen und der bekam dann irgendwann sozusagen zweiten Reviewer, weiß ich nicht, bewilligt oder also es sollte dann einen zweiten Reviewer geben und der hat da natürlich seinen besten Spätzle reingesetzt und das ist natürlich doof, weil Geocaching und da achtet Groundspeak schon auch auf eine gewisse Art drauf, es ist ein breiten Sport. Geocaching machen alle Leute, machen kleine Kinder, machen alte Leute, das machen Rentner, das machen Karriere-Risten, das machen Millionäre, das machen, also das machen einfach alle Leute.
Seid sogar Podcaster.
Genau, es gibt ja auch Geocaching-Podcasts. In Berlin gab es mal den Cash Talk eine Weile, der ist eingestellt, es gibt jetzt noch den Geo-Quassel, in Hamburg gibt es den Berufsgeocacher, dann auch in Norddeutschland die schon erwähnten Dosenfischer und ganz, ganz viele andere. Also ich habe da vor zwei, drei Jahren war ich da mal aktiv und habe auch im Cash Talk relativ viel mitgemacht. Ich bin jetzt so bezüglich Aktualität, was gerade am Podcast so angesagt ist.
Aber auch Podcaster tun das und das ist alles sehr ernsthaft.
Genau, Astronauten tun das auch übrigens. Es gibt auch einen Geocache an der ISS.
Wer hat den angelegt?
Irgendso ein Astronaut, glaube ich. Wirklich? Der hat die GC Nummer GC1BE91, heißt International Space Station. Ich hab noch kein Mal gefunden. Wann wurde der denn angelegt? Ich guck gerade mal. 14. Oktober 2008, versteckt von Richard Garriott.
Den hat noch keiner gefunden? Aber da sind doch regelmäßig Leute.
Naja, aber die müssen ja auch Geocacher sein. Ja, und der hatte zum Beispiel, als er den Cash gelegt hat, das Problem, du darfst ja kein Papier mitnehmen, weil es zu leicht brennbar ist. Und deswegen hat er hier ein Bild gemacht, das sieht man auf dem Listing. Da siehst du so ein Dogtag von so einem Travel Bug. Das ist doch so ein Bug, so ein stilisierter Käfer draufgemalt. Und das musst du sozusagen finden und davon die trackable Nummer finden, dann darfst du diesen Cash als gelockt.
Das scheint mir jetzt nicht sehr schwierig zu sein.
Dann machen wir eine Fortsetzung CRI zum Thema Geocaching. Um jedenfalls nochmal auf den Lost in Space wie passend zurückzukommen, dieser Geocacher, den ich ja kennenlernte bei meiner ersten Stammtische, den Review-Prozess. Der hatte nämlich den Verdacht, dass es...
Also Lost in Space ist sein Name.
Nein, der ist der Name des Caches. Und der Cash-Owner hatte den Verdacht, dass die Reviewer Final-Koordinaten rausgeben für die FTFer.
Für die First-to-Find-Fraktion.
Genau, und dass es auch Reviewer möglicherweise gibt, die genau wissen, dass bestimmte Bekannte von ihnen zu bestimmten Zeiten gut immer losziehen können, um den First-to-Find zu machen.
Also sie biegen sozusagen Caches, bevor sie veröffentlicht sind, damit die anderen sich frühzeitig an die Backe kleben können, dass sie die ersten waren.
Genau. Wer diesen Verdacht hatte, hat folgenden Trick gemacht. Der hat im Listing die Mystery-Koordinaten angegeben. Das wissen wir jetzt, die stimmen ja nicht. Der eigentliche Final ist im Umkreis von 3 km von diesen Koordinaten. Da musst du aber dem Reviewer die tatsächlichen Koordinaten angeben, damit er die Abstandsprüfung machen kann. Es gibt auch eine Abstandsregel von Cash zu Cash. Also ein Cash muss mindestens 160 Meter entfernt sein. Ah, 160. Genau, deswegen brauchen die Reviewer auch immer die tatsächlichen Final-Koordinaten, auch von der Mystery. Da musst du hinterlegen. Und weil er diesen Verdacht hatte, hat er aber dem Reviewer Koordinaten gesagt, die nicht ganz stimmten. Und dann ist Folgendes passiert, das Ding ist rausgekommen und es haben sich FTFer bei ihm gemeldet und haben gesagt, da an den Koordinaten, also wir haben das Rätsel gelöst, aber bei den Koordinaten ist kein Cache, du musst da auch mal eine Dose hinlegen. Dann hat der gefragt, ja bei welchen Koordinaten habt ihr denn gesucht? Und dann haben offensichtlich einige die Koordinaten angegeben, also die falschen, die er dem Reviewer gesagt hat.
Die aber so in dem Listing, war das so ein Mystery-Cache? Also das war nicht wirklich die Lösung, sondern nur das, was der Reviewer meinte, was die Lösung sei, weil er es ja direkt gesagt bekommen hat.
Genau. Und da hat er sich natürlich keine Freunde gemacht in der Szene.
Der Reviewer?
Nee, der Cash-Owner. War natürlich dann sauer auf den Cash-Owner, ist ja klar, wie immer.
Na toll, der Überbringer der schlechten Nachrichten wird sozusagen wieder gekillt.
Ja, genau.
Aber eigentlich hat der Reviewer ja Trick am Stecken.
Aber gut, es ist ja auch nur ein Hobby. Ich finde ja auch, man muss das alles immer nicht so eng sehen.
Nee, da muss man jetzt total ernst. Gibt es da keine Gerichtsbarkeiten?
Ja, Mord und Totschlag. Mord und Totschlag, ich sag's dir.
Der Reviewer scheint ja genauso im Stritt zu sein wie Wikipedia.
Geocacher sind schlimmer als Blogger.
Schlimmer als Blogger? Du bist ja auch Bloggerin, du weißt ja, wovon du redest.
Ich hab ja auch damals die Hochzeiten von Donald Fonso mitbekommen. Also ich weiß wirklich, wovon ich rede.
Hast die Hochzeit vorbei.
Ich hab so den Eindruck.
Diese First-Hoe-Feind-Fraktion, man kann das jetzt auch sportlich sehen. Also ich meine, abgesehen von den Leuten, die sich jetzt mit den Reviewern da verbünden, die finden das einfach toll, sozusagen Geocaching und können sich nichts Tolleres vorstellen, als da ihre Street Cred zu bekommen, um einfach mal die Ersten zu sein. Das heißt, es gibt auch schon so, wie das immer so ist, so ein Rewarding-System innerhalb dieser Community. Und es gibt auch eine Community. Also Leute kennen sich.
Auf jeden Fall. Also in Berlin zum Beispiel gibt es einen monatlichen Stammtisch. Der findet immer an unterschiedlichen Locations statt, je nachdem, wer jetzt auch gerade was organisiert. Und da kommen selten unter 60 Leute. Meistens bewegt sich das so zwischen 60, 120, es können auch mal 150 werden.
Monatliches Treffen.
Monatlich.
150 Leute.
Und das sind aber nur die Engagierten in der Berliner Community.
Wird der Ort dann immer bekannt gegeben? Wird da auch erstmal ein Cache?
Gibt es einen Event-Cache. Event-Cache ist, Geocacher treffen sich, besaufen sich und kriegen dafür einen Found-Punkt.
Was heißt, so einen Event-Cache kann man auch anlegen, ohne jetzt durch so einen Review-Prozess durchgehen zu müssen?
Nee, der geht auch durch einen Review-Prozess. Der muss auch, glaub ich, mindestens, also spätestens zwei Wochen, bevor das Event stattfinden soll, muss das Listing auch durch sein. Naja, damit die Leute noch Zeit haben, auch hinzugehen.
Ja, ja, ich meine, ich weiß jetzt ja nicht, mit welcher Frequenz neue Caches so entstehen, aber das ist ja dann schon eine gewisse Auftragslast, die auf dieser Reviewer-Abteilung lastet.
Du könntest zum Beispiel mal die Seite geocachingberlin.de ansurfen.
Surfen bin ich die Spitze.
So, da gibt's einen Haufen hier Karten, Logs und Statistik. Und da kannst du zum Beispiel mal auf Logs gehen. Da siehst du links einen Filter. Cache ist neu, genau. Da siehst du auch schon GC und OC. OC ist für Open Caching. Es gibt auch noch andere Plattformen als geocaching.com. So, und dann gehst du mal auf Anzeigen.
Das ist PMO.
Das weiß ich gerade auch nicht. Ich sehe das auch gar nicht hier bei mir, aber wie auch immer. Nee, auf Logs. Du bist bei Karten ganz oben im Hauptmenü. Logs, genau, veröffentlicht. Und hier siehst du jetzt mal eben eine Übersicht von Caches, die gerade veröffentlicht wurden. Also 14.10. haben wir zum Beispiel hier eins, zwei, drei, vier. Sechs Stück, genau. Und darunter 13.10. ganz viele.
Oha, eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf.
Und da siehst du auch, welche Reviewer das waren. Da ist hier der Approvee, also Approve. Anhalto, Sherlock, Maxwell Smart. So, und da siehst du halt, also es gibt wohl im Moment so, weiß ich nicht, vier, fünf aktive Reviewer.
Mister oder Mrs. Approve sind hier auf jeden Fall gut unterwegs.
Ja, ich vermute auch, dass hinter so manchen Reviewer-Accounts halt auch mehrere Reviewer stecken.
Ah, so Gruppen.
Ja, was ich auch sinnvoll finde, weil da das Geocaching ja eine ganz toterne Sache ist, ist so Reviewer-Dasein auch kein leichtes Leben.
Weil?
Na, man, also, man ist Anfeindungen unterlegen?
Weil man...
Na ja, wie konnte man diesen Cash nur veröffentlichen? Der ist zum Beispiel auf dem, also Cash auf dem Spielplatz, ganz schlimm. Geht gar nicht. Totales No-Go.
Warum?
Na ja, wie soll man denn? Also der durchschnittliche Geocacher ist halt so der durchschnittliche Mensch, ne? Weiß, mittleren Alters, männlich. Wenn sich so einer in der Nähe von einem Kinderspielplatz rumtreibt, auf so ein Device guckt und so verdächtig im Gebüsch rumkrabbelt, und auf Anderen rumklettert. Ja, aber das ist echt so... Das ist halt der Mainstream, das ist halt die Masse, ja? Wo natürlich jede Frau, die zum Beispiel alleinerziehend ist, also ich bade gerade mal ein bisschen in Klischees, ja, sagt, wieso, ich finde das toll. Wenn ich da auf der Bank sitze, dann muss ich nicht häkeln, ich kann einen Cash suchen gehen. Ja, also ich meine, also der Hass auf Spielplatz-Cashes ist wirklich auch eine Frage von Gender Gaps.
Gibt es da noch so andere umstrittene Klassiker?
Friedhöfe natürlich ist klar, aber das kann man vielleicht so ein bisschen nachvollziehen wegen Störungen der Totenruhe und so. Also direkt an einem Grab ein Cash legen, vielleicht nur so halb optimal. Und naja gut, also zum Beispiel in Berlin gibt es natürlich auch einen Haufen Plätze, wo Geocaches liegen, sind einfach vermüllt. Man sollte auch nicht unterhalb der Pippi-Grenze liegen. Ne, ne, unterhalb der Pippi-Grenze, also eigentlich am besten in einer Großstadt nicht auf dem Boden.
Also hochhängen.
Naja, also ich sag mal so.
Ich hänge den höher.
Also mir fehlt da ja sozusagen ein bisschen die biologische Grundlage, um die richtige Minimalhöhe angeben zu können. Aber ich denke mal so über 70, 80 Zentimeter sollte man vielleicht gehen.
Das sind so Aspekte, die muss man auch erst mal.
Naja, also ich sag mal so, als Cash-Owner möchte man schlussendlich eigentlich seinen lieben Mit-Cashern ein erfreuliches Erlebnis bieten. Und das muss man sich halt vorher überlegen. Will ich den Leuten wirklich zumuten, den Müll greifen zu müssen? Kann man, man kann es ja machen. Es gibt ja vielleicht auch Leute, die es toll finden. Die haben auch dann Handschuhe dabei und dann geht es alles.
Aber jeder Cash hat auch gleich so einen Namen.
Genau.
Der dann schon mal vielleicht irgendwas sagt darüber, was das so sein könnte. Was weiß ich hier, ab an die Euter. Was ist Grün?
Grün ist ein Tradi.
Okay, so, und dann kann man den jetzt hier anklickshornen.
Genau. Jetzt kommst du zum Listing zur Webseite von dem Cash.
Zweieinhalb Difficulty.
Genau.
Eineinhalb Terra.
Also könnte er auf einer Wiese liegen.
Ja, der liegt, hier sieht man ja auf der Kartenausschnitt. Was ist denn das? Das ist nordöstlich von Färbelin.
An irgendeinem Wanderweg oder an einem Trampelpfad oder sowas. Wenn ich das jetzt hier richtig deute.
Genau, und die Größe ist ein Mikro, also da wird irgendwo in der Pampa eine Filmbose rumliegen.
Irgendwo im Wald. Genau. Okay, dann schreibt man noch ein bisschen was dazu und gut ist.
Unser erster Cash, ja das ist immer ganz, ganz super. Unser erster Cash, schöne Natur und Umgebung. Also es gibt Menschen, die haben da eine Abneigung dagegen. Es gibt auch ganz viele Caches, die heißen unser erster Cash. So, und dann guckst du halt vielleicht auf das Profil von dem Cash-Owner, dann siehst du, der hat erst 20 gefunden. Ja, was wird das wohl sein? Na klar, der hat halt irgendwo eine Filmbose hingelegt.
Das heißt wir könnten jetzt hier diesen Cash-Owner gleich mal hinterher schnuppern und mal schauen?
Da guck mal, 18 Caches gefunden. Also, manchmal sind da schöne Sachen dabei. Und es gibt auch zum Beispiel auch um Berlin rum, also Brandenburg gibt es etliche Cash-Löcher. Das siehst du auf dieser Google Map-Karte bei Geocaching. Da liegen einfach keine Caches. Und da gab es zum Beispiel eine Cash-Serie, die hieß GZEDCDIB. So, alle Caches, die da gelegt wurden, die hatten diese Abkürzung am Anfang und dann den Titel. Und das war die Abkürzung für Geocache zur Erhöhung der Cash-Dichte in Brandenburg. Und das ist halt einfach, also der Berliner an und für sich fährt halt gerne ins Umland. Und auch der Berliner Geocacher möchte sich halt gerne auch im Berliner Umland geocachenderweise fortbewegen. Wenn aber mal 30 Kilometer lang gar kein Cache ist, dann möchte man da auch gerne Dosen haben. Und da ist natürlich hier so ein, unser erster, dann vielleicht halt auch einfach eine willkommene Abwechslung.
Ich gucke jetzt einfach mal, was bei mir so rumliegt hier, um die Meta-Ebene herum.
Ich habe hier schon mit meinem Smartphone eine Location-Based-Abfrage gemacht. Doch.
Wo denn?
Hier zum Beispiel der Teddy, der ist gerade deaktiviert. Aber der, den du da oben siehst, das ist wahrscheinlich der, wo es immer regnet.
Mach ich gerade irgendwas falsch? Oder warum ist hier überall nichts?
Ne, du hast ein Berliner Cash-Loch entdeckt.
Ich wohne in einem Berliner Cash-Loch.
Aber du bist ja auch nicht so begeistert vom Geocaching.
Ja, bei dem Angebot, wo es immer regnet.
Guck mal, von den dreiköpfigen Affen. Da hinter dir. Ein dreiköpfiger Affe. Mit dem dreiköpfigen Affen, das war doch aus irgendeinem Computerspiel.
War das nicht aus diesem?
Monkey Island? Es gibt nämlich zum Beispiel auch in der Nähe vom Mögelsee, wo sie viele Geocacher fragen, ob die Muggles da herkommen. Und auch Harry Potter-Fans fragen sich, ist das der See, wo die Muggles herkommen? Der Mugglesee. Da gibt es zum Beispiel eine Monkey Island-Multi-Cache-Serie, die vom Erlebnis her sehr, sehr nah am Computerspielerlebnis sein soll.
Das heißt, die Rätsel aus dem Spiel werden da quasi in reale Caches umgesetzt?
Und teilweise auch wirklich ähnliche Gegenden, also ein bisschen sumpfiger, oder viele Mücken oder whatever.
So, die kann ich irgendwie nicht weiterzoomen. Ist das Absicht?
Reicht ja. Das ist der Teddy, der ist deaktiviert.
Das siehst du daran, dass er grau ist. Ach so. Wie genau gibt man denn die Koordinaten an? Und wie genau werden sie einem vermittelt? Also wie genau ist die Auflösung der GPS-Koordinate? Kann ich davon ausgehen, dass wenn ich jetzt die volle Auflösung benutze und die hier auch so hinterlege, dass die mir dann auch so wiedergegeben wird? Ich meine, hier gibt es ja mehrere Nachkommastellen. Das sollte ja schon mal helfen.
In der Regel ist man natürlich gerade bei einem Tradi bemüht, die Koordinaten relativ genau anzugeben. Also wir gehen jetzt mal davon aus, dass ein Cash-Owner das tun möchte. Also wirklich möglichst genau kennzeichnen. Dann hängt die Genauigkeit von zwei Faktoren natürlich ab. Nämlich erstens, wie genau ist sein GPS-Gerät? Wie genau nimmt er die Koordinaten? Also meinen GPS hier habe ich mal mitgebracht. Das hat zum Beispiel eine Funktion Waypoint Averaging nennt sich das. Das heißt, wenn ich das klicke, dann nimmt das zwischen ein und drei Minuten lang, macht das sozusagen 100 Koordinaten-Stichproben.
Und bildet dann den Mittelpunkt daraus?
Bildet daraus den Mittelpunkt. Das sollte dann relativ genau sein. Dann gehe ich auf Google Maps und gebe die Koordinaten dort ein und versuche dann auf Google Maps abzugleichen, ob das tatsächlich möglichst genau der Ort ist, wo ich die Dose hingelegt habe. Also ich habe zum Beispiel ja auch einen Cache versteckt. Das ist der zweitmeist gefaffte Geocache Berlins. Wir haben die Faffpoints noch gar nicht erklärt, wie die funktionieren. Wir haben GC Vote erklärt, auch noch nicht die Faffpoints.
Na du hast sie erwähnt, aber...
Die Faffpoints sind das Favoritensystem von Groundspeak. Und das funktioniert so, das dürfte dir auch ein bisschen mehr entgegenkommen. Wenn du zehn Geocaches gefunden hast, darfst du einen Faffpoint vergeben. Und für diesen, also ich habe meinen Geocache in der Nähe vom hackischen Markt gelegt. Da ist wahnsinnig schlechter GPS-Empfang. Das springt immer, du hast ja immer springende Koordinaten. Die schieben dich mal auf die eine Straßenseite, mal auf die andere. Also das kann teilweise 10 Meter in die Irre gehen.
Ja, in Städten ist es halt generell problematisch.
Genau. Und da habe ich halt geguckt, dass ich in Google Maps eben möglichst genau das einzeichne, weil du siehst ja, wenn du hier auf den Cash guckst, dann siehst du auf Google Maps, wo der liegt im Prinzip. Und du kannst da schon sehen, ah, der ist da an der Straßenecke vorausgesetzt. Der Owner hat sich eben die Mühe gemacht, das auch nochmal abzugleichen. Also das ist die zweite Ungenauigkeitsquelle. Also hat er sozusagen den Wegpunkt ordentlich genommen mit guten Werten. Hat er auf Google Maps das nochmal abgeglichen, ob das auch wirklich hinkommt. Und das dritte ist dann natürlich, wie gut das mein eigenes GPS ist. Ich kann natürlich die Koordinaten eingeben, aber wenn ich selber springende Koordinaten habe, dann nutzt mir das gar nichts.
Aber müssen das sich die Reviewer so ein bisschen abfangen?
Das kannst du nicht wissen.
Weil die da nicht hingehen, oder was?
Nee, also die Reviewer gucken nur nach den formalen Sachen. Also es gibt Reviewer, die selbst sehr viele Caches haben und dann vielleicht gucken. Oder ein bisschen mehr Vorstellungskraft besitzen, was ein gutes Listing ist oder so. Aber das kannst du von einem Reviewern nicht verlangen. Also acht Caches am Tag veröffentlichen, selbst wenn mehrere dahinterstecken.
Okay, da habe ich das so ein bisschen missverstanden. Ich dachte ursprünglich, dass es vielleicht tatsächlich mal so abgenommen werden muss. Aber es ist natürlich vielleicht auch ein bisschen vermessen, jeden erstmal in den Berg hochglittern zu lassen, bevor man so ein Ding veröffentlicht. Also er kann es nicht überprüfen.
Genau. Aber in der Regel ist es so, die ersten Leute gehen halt hin. Gerade diese ersten Logs sind ja auch immer ein bisschen aussagekräftig, ob der Cache nur gut wird oder nicht. Wenn da jemand schreibt, da liegt keine Dose, und das ist fünfmal passiert, dann sagt der Reviewer auch, okay, das Listing wird erstmal wieder disabled. Wird da auch da wirklich eine Dose hinlegen? Also nicht nur einfach ein Listing veröffentlichen, sondern auch eine Dose hinlegen. Da gab es zum Beispiel mal eine Schulklasse, da hat der Lehrer wahrscheinlich sich gefreut, dass er mal ein schönes Experiment machen kann mit den Schülern, hat die dann halt mal ein Cache legen lassen. Die haben dann auch das Listing veröffentlicht, haben aber vier Monate lang keine Dose da hingelegt. Die haben ja immer wieder reingeschrieben, ja, am so und sovielten um 11.42 Uhr werden wir die Dose hinlegen. Da gab es dann irgendwie fünf solche Einträge. Das ist also immer so ein bisschen die Befürchtung, wenn man halt sieht, da wird ein Cache gelegt von einem Owner, der entweder noch keine Caches selbst gefunden hat oder sehr wenige, dass da sozusagen ein bisschen so die Idee fehlt, was ein guter Cache ist. Nicht halt einfach nur eine Dose hinwerfen, so jetzt sucht man hahaha, sondern eben vielleicht einen schönen Cache zu legen.
Und wenn die hier grau sind, dann sind die nicht mehr da?
Nee, dann sind sie deaktiviert, disabled. Die dürfen im Moment nicht gefunden werden, entweder weil die Dose weg ist und der Owner sagt, dann hier erstmal nicht mehr suchen damit, weil die Dose ist nicht da, bis ich wieder eine Dose hingelegt habe, dann wird der Cache wieder enabled, dann wird er wieder freigegeben.
Das heißt, man wird schon so ein bisschen Pater auch von seinen Caches?
Ja, dass nur Cache-Owner sein ist mit sehr hoher Verantwortung verbunden.
Ich glaube, so eine Fehlwahrnehmung, die sich bei mir auch so ein bisschen spontan abgebildet hat, ist so dieses, man rennt halt überall rum und setzt so seine Duftmarken und dann war's das. Dann macht man da nichts mehr. Aber es ist eigentlich sehr viel mehr, dass man sich so einen Ort sucht und da so ein bisschen ein eigenes Lokal aufmacht. Das ist sozusagen so ein Ort, wo ich Leute hinschicken möchte und denen da so eine Experience, so eine Finding-Experience, Credenzen möchte und ich kümmere mich dann auch darum, dass das Ding am Leben bleibt.
So sieht's aus.
Ich freue mich dann auch darüber, wenn Leute sich dafür entscheiden, den da zu finden und zu bewerten.
Also es gibt zum Beispiel welche, die haben einen Nachtcash gelegt in der Nähe von Potsdam. Also ein Cash, den du mit Taschenlampen machst oder mit UV-Lampen. Also Taschenlampen und UV-Lampen, das ist ein ganz großes Thema in der Geocaching-Szene neben den GPS-Devices natürlich. Das ist so das Gadget schlechthin, Taschenlampen. Und die haben diesen Cash wohl so aufwändig gestaltet, dass sie von vornherein gesagt haben, sobald die 100 Leute gefunden haben werden, machen wir den zu, weil wir können den nicht mehr maintainen. Also wir können die Wartungsarbeit auf Dauer nicht mehr aufrecht erhalten. Und da meldest du dich quasi vorher an und die kommen dann und checken und helfen dir quasi so ein bisschen durch und gucken, dass auch wirklich alles in Ordnung ist.
Aber du wirst so richtig begleitet?
Naja, begleitet nicht ganz direkt, aber die checken vorher, dass wirklich auch alle Stationen in Ordnung sind. Also gerade bei Nachcaches, da gibt es dann zum Beispiel so Spielchen mit... Also du kannst Reflektoren suchen natürlich, ist klar. Dann gehst du mit der Taschenlampe durch und guckst an Reflektoren, wo es jetzt weitergeht.
Das wird doch wieder bei der Schatzsuche.
Es gibt zum Beispiel welche, wo du... Da musst du einen Laserpointer mitnehmen, dem musst du dann eine bestimmte Station, eine bestimmte Vorrichtung legen, der pointet dann irgendwo hin und da musst du dann als nächstes hingehen, zum Beispiel.
Oder mit zu spiegeln?
Oder mit Spiegeln oder was auch immer. Oder es gibt so dieses, ich glaube, reflexive Lichter, Lichter, die angehen, wenn sie von einer Taschenlampe beleuchtet werden. Also wenn Licht mit einer bestimmten Stärke auf die trifft, dann aktivieren die sich. Da hatte ich schon mal bei einem Nachcash, dass dann ein Morse-Code über Lichtsignale abgegeben wird. Den musst du dann decodieren und darüber kommst du dann zu den nächsten Koordinaten.
Toll, jetzt weiß ich endlich mal, was ich hier mit meinem Laserpointer anfangen kann. Der liegt hier schon seit längerem rum.
Also in Sachen Gadgets kannst du damit dich auf jeden Geocaching-Stammtisch trauen. Ja, das geht völlig durch, ist total in Ordnung.
Ich bin ja totale Elite Pro-Casher.
Ich habe zum Beispiel hier meine Taschenlampe mitgebracht.
Zeig doch mal deinen... Das fände ich jetzt sowieso noch mal ein interessantes Thema.
Das ist was Geocacher machen. Die leuchten dann mit ihren Taschenlampen, stehen dann ineinander, leuchten mit ihren Taschenlampen hier die Wand an. Dann sagen sie, guck mal, wie doll meine kann.
Ist doch nix hier, guck dir mal meinen Laserpunkt an.
Du, ich pack hier gleich mal noch meinen Supergadget aus.
Okay, aber die braucht man auch.
Für Nachtcash auf jeden Fall.
Das scheint nochmal so ein extra Sport zu sein.
Aber es hilft auch bei Tag. Was hast du denn für eine Lampe? Das ist hier eine Phoenix TK-15. Die kommt aus dem Waffenzubehör. Die hat hier so einen Waffenring. Die kannst du auch auf deine Sniper vorne drauf machen. Genau.
Phoenix, F-E-N-I-X, nie gehört.
Also ich finde die ganz gut, weil die ist klein. Und du hast ja gesehen, die kann schon ganz ordentlich hell machen.
Hochleistungs-LED-Taschenlampe.
Ja, heißer Scheiß, sage ich dir. Heißer Scheiß. Der Anknopf ist hinten dran.
Achso. Und was ist das da vorne? Nein, genau.
Wenn du den aber kürzer oder länger drückst, dann fängt er auch an zu flaschen.
Oh Gott, ich kriege gleich einen epileptischen Anfall, wenn ich aufpasse. Macht hell auf jeden Fall. Ich kann das jetzt gerade nicht so richtig im Vergleich setzen, aber das ist natürlich bei den Lichtverhältnissen ja auch schwierig.
Also dem Beamer überstrahle ich locker damit.
Aber die macht auf jeden Fall ordentlich Wurm und vor allem ist sie stabil. Geht nicht kaputt, wenn sie runterfällt. Genau.
Und handlich. Passt auch mal eben so noch in die Tasche rein. Ja, und hilft halt auch tagsüber, weil wenn du mal in so ein, zum Beispiel hier, Stichwort braun, brauner Nano, in braunem Holz, kannst du auch mal ableuchten, weil der Nano reflektiert anders als das Holz. Kann also auch bei Tag helfen.
Ist denn, also ich meine, wenn man sich so ein Geocache jetzt so ein bisschen mehr so als, ich meine, also eigentlich ist es ja so ein bisschen so ein Eventort, so mein privater Eventmagnet, wo ich irgendwie Leute hinziehe.
Meine private Schatzsuche.
Und da habe ich dann Spaß daran, dass Leute daran Spaß haben, da einen abzufeiern. Jetzt mit dieser hohen Nörddichte könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das auch alles so ein bisschen, ich meine heutzutage haben wir es jetzt in zunehmendem Maße, auch mit so problemlos batteriebetreibbaren WLAN-Beacons. Weißt du, worauf ich hinausfälle? Dass man da so quasi mehr so Computer schon platziert und dann vielleicht schon nach der passenden SSID suchen muss, um Spaß zu haben.
Gibt es, ist natürlich immer ein bisschen, gerade USB-Sticks zum Beispiel ein Problem wegen Viren und so weiter.
Wenn man so einen Webserver dahin baut, der sozusagen sein eigenes kleines WLAN abstrahlt, nur in zwei Meter Umfeld, da bucht man sich dann ein und dann könnte man natürlich auch die Bitcoin-Wallet, die du anfangs schon angesprochen hast, problemlos...
Ich hab zum Beispiel einen Cash gemacht in Graz, der wurde von einem Owner gelegt, der an den Stadtinformations-Monitoring-System gearbeitet hat. Du grinst schon so, du kannst dir glaub ich schon vorstellen, worauf das hinausläuft. Ich hoffe, ich spoiler jetzt nicht zu viel, aber da ich ja den Namen des Caches auch nicht nenne, geht das und auch nicht genau sage, was man machen muss, geht das vielleicht gerade noch so in Ordnung. Da kommst du sozusagen bei den Startkoordinaten zu so einem von diesen Monitoren, wo du dann freies Internet Zugang hast. Und da steht dann im Listing, mach das, was wir immer tun. Du sollst das Listing abrufen. Und das ist halt manipuliert. Du siehst da, der checkt sozusagen ab, greift gerade jemand von diesem Punkt auf das Listing zu und dann ist das Listing anders, als wenn du das jetzt von hier abrufen würdest.
So was meinte ich. Digitale Spielereien. Aber gerade so dieses... Na, jetzt stecken wir gerade so in diesem Internet of Things-Ding. Und mittlerweile kann man so batteriebetriebene, WLAN-fähige Prozessoren in Subdaumennagelgröße, die jahrelang vor sich hin funken, das ist jetzt einfach machbar. Das ist irgendwie kein Thema mehr. Und kostet auch nicht viel.
Ich hab den Geocaching-Daumen. Jedes Mal, wenn ich einem ein Cache vorbeilaufe, dann ist der so bzz bzz bzz.
Ja, so ein bisschen so eine reaktive Welt, so eine digital angereicherte Welt. Also Augmented Reality mal anders. Ich lege nicht einen privaten Layer optisch über die Welt, sondern die Welt wird selber digital kommunikativ. Und wenn man halt so rumläuft, scannt man quasi den Ort. Der WLAN-Strahl wird zu einer digitalen Taschenlampe, weil die Dinger sich erst bemerkbar machen, wenn ich da halt mit meinem Zauberstab rumwusel um einen Harry Potter-Vergleichswelt.
Könnte man machen. Ja, also da ist natürlich wirklich ein Spiel rein, Tür und Tor geöffnet. Es gibt jetzt seit einiger Zeit von Garmin ein sogenanntes Chirp. Das ist eben genau so ein reaktives Ding. Das reagiert darauf, dass dein Garmin GPS-Device, also das ist auch hier ein bisschen Vault-Garden, das muss dann chirpfähig sein. Ja genau, siehst du auch schon den ersten Google-Eintrag. Eine gute Idee, aber.
Das ist ja so ein Beacon im Prinzip, ne?
Und wenn das sozusagen Signal bekommt von deinem GPS, dann schickt dir das auf dein GPS-Information.
Ah ja, genau, so was, genau, und so in die Richtung. Garmin ist ja ein sehr bekannter Hersteller von High-End GPS-Devices. Ich glaube im Telefonbereich, da werden sie nicht mehr so viel bewegen.
Mein erstes GPS war ein Garmin NavTalk. Das war ein Handy mit GPS-Funktionalität.
Sie sind ja einer der, wenn nicht sogar der, frühe GPS-Device-Anbieter, die es erst mal so richtig getaugt haben. Die ist auch in allen Formen und Farben. Du hast ja auch ein Garmin GPS, was ist das für ein Gerät?
Das ist ein Oregon 550 mit Touchscreen.
Oregon 550. Und im Vergleich zu so, ich meine, warum jetzt nicht einfach nur Telefon?
Also meine Erfahrung ist, ich mache ja manchmal beides. Ich bin immer mit Smartphone und mit dem GPS unterwegs. Smartphone verwende ich eben, um Caches in der Nähe und Listings abrufen zu können, weil das Garmin GPS hat ja kein Internet. Und ich gebe dann meistens über die Koordinaten, die ich finde, im GPS ein. Also ich kann natürlich auch im GPS einfach klicken, navigiere mich dahin. Geht natürlich auch nahtlos sozusagen. Ich habe aber die Erfahrung gemacht, dass das GPS und auch die Kompassfunktion vom, also nativen GPS-Device sozusagen genauer ist als die von den Smartphones. Da ist halt die Peilung manchmal beeinträchtigt, dadurch, dass andere Apps laufen, dass nebenher irgendwie Internetverkehr stattfindet, dass, ja, was weiß ich, irgendwas gerade haaklich läuft und so weiter und so weiter. Und das habe ich halt eben bei diesem Garmin-Ding habe ich das halt einfach nicht.
Hier ist ja auch richtig Geocache als Feature drauf.
Genau, ich kann mir da, also du kannst dir von jedem Geocache so eine GPX-Datei runterziehen. Die lade ich dann auf das Garmin drauf und kann den dann als Geocache auch aufrufen.
Per Bluetooth oder USB oder was?
In dem Fall per USB, genau. Das ist auch schon auch eine richtige Struktur.
Das heißt, dass sich die Caches ja auch jetzt nicht laufend ändern. Also es gibt zwar immer wieder neue, aber gewisse Stabilität gibt es ja schon so im Geocache-Umfeld, oder? Ist das sehr volatil?
Ja, wie gesagt, kommt immer drauf an, wo man wohnt. Also in Berlin passiert natürlich immer eine Menge. Da kann schon eine Aufgabe sein, seine Homezone sauber zu halten, sozusagen. Also alles zu finden. Aber wenn du jetzt irgendwo in so einem Cash-Loch in Brandenburg lebst, wo im Umkreis von 5 km gerade mal 3 Caches liegen, wenn überhaupt.
Da bewegt sich nicht so viel. Auf jeden Fall kann man zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt halt mal alles so sich runterladen. Es gibt wahrscheinlich auch genau diese Funktionen.
Es gibt auch Caches along the Route. Du kannst auch sagen, ich will da und da hinfahren. Jetzt spuck mir mal alle Geocaches aus. Du lädst halt eine gbx-Datei von deiner Route hoch. Sagst dann, gib mir mal alle zum Beispiel Tradis, die nicht höher sind als die T-Wertungen, weiß ich nicht, 3, 2. Es ist noch angenehm, dass man die so auf der Durchreise mitnehmen kann zum Beispiel. Und die halt nicht weiter als 3 km von der Route entfernt sind. Ja, oder mit dem Auto oder... Also was ich sehr gerne mag, ist mit dem Motorrad. Ich mach dann ebenso richtig Routenplanung auch. Also ich weiß, ich kann 200 km fahren und dabei 12 Caches finden. Wenn ich mehr Kilometer fahren will, werden es weniger Caches. Wenn es weniger Kilometer sind, kann ich mehr Caches machen. Das ist bei mir so ungefähr die Daumenregel. Und ich suche mir dann schon ziemlich bewusst... Also ich versuche dann nicht Autobahn zu fahren, nicht so Hauptstrecken zu fahren und suche mir dann immer Geocaches aus, die so ein bisschen abseits liegen. Und dann cache ich mich da so durch. Und ich finde das sehr angenehm, wenn ich abends halt nicht... Also ich fahre nicht Motorrad und will irgendwo dann am Ende des Tages ankommen, sondern ich fahre einfach so von cache zu cache. Zwischendurch mal ein bisschen absteigen, ein bisschen Bewegung haben. Das Suchen ist ja auch eine andere Aufmerksamkeit, als eben da dauernd das Motorradfahren und so. Also finde ich eine sehr angenehme Art zu reisen.
Was hast du denn noch so für Gerät?
Ich hab also, ich hab hier noch, ich hab was super Neuliges, hab ich noch dabei. Es gab mal eine Zeit lang diese, so eine Mode bei manchen Caches. Wenn man in den Caches ist, hat man Cache-Karten gefunden. Ich hab nie jemanden gesehen, der das wirklich gemacht hat. Oder ich wurde da auch nie auf Stammtischen drauf angesprochen, wenn ich mal andere Menschen gefragt hab, ob die Cache-Cards haben. Ja, hm, nee und so.
Aber das ist so eine Karte, die quasi wie ein Listing ist. Also, die den Cache beschreibt.
Genau.
Petrovitsch Schanze. Multicache. Okay, mit so einem kleinen Foto. Das heißt, du gehst dann, also findest an dem Cache quasi noch die Cache-Karte für den Cache dazu.
Genau, da liegt dann in der Dose, die man findet, liegt dann so ein Stapel mit Karten und da kann man sich an einen mitnehmen.
Ah, sehr fancy.
Hast du ein Messer oder ein Schlüssel für mich oder so?
Hier müssen immer viele Pakete geöffnet werden.
Ja genau, sowas hab ich jetzt auch vor.
Da hab ich auch immer passende Gadget da. Hier guck mal, mein Büroskypick. Die gut in der Hand.
Krasses Ding.
So, was machst du da jetzt? Jetzt kommt dieses Live-Unboxing, was du vorhin schon angekündigt hast.
Genau, ich hab mir ein Gadget bestellt.
Das erste Unboxing hier in einem Audio-Podcast. Jetzt wird gerade das Büroskypick treffsicher in die dafür vorgesehenen Rillen eingeführt. Mit ein bitzter Hand wird hier der Inhalt extrahiert, eingewickelt wie ein Fisch in Zeitungspapier. Da finden sich dort unverdächtige weiße längliche Kiste. Und darin fancy Taschenlampen, weil die andere noch nicht hell genug war. Ist das nicht genau die gleiche?
Nee, ist das nicht genau die gleiche. Aber ich hoffe, es ist diesmal auch die richtige. Ich habe mir die nämlich schon mal bestellt und habe aber die falsche geliefert bekommen. Jetzt würde ich dich bitten, mal diese Batterie reinzulegen.
Upsa, was denn das für eine Batterie?
Das ist ein 18650 Akku.
Ja, Schraub schraub, hinten oder was?
Ja, vermute ich.
Ja, okay, ich bin mal gespannt. Und hier so ein Teil in der Hand gehabt. Jetzt sind wir ja ohne Akku. Womit lebt man das? Ist das Ladegerät dabei?
Ich habe mir eins extra dafür bestellt, aber da ich jetzt zwei Taschenlampen damit betreibe, dachte ich... Ja, ich habe ihn ja hier schon drin gehabt. Der ist ja nicht mitgeliefert worden.
Das ist jetzt auch wieder für die Nightcash-Fraktion, oder funktioniert das auch tagsüber?
Na ja, du siehst es schon relativ stark. Also es sollte tagsüber mit der Lampe auch gehen. Ich würde dich bitten, mir damit nicht in die Augen zu leuchten.
Nee, habe ich auch nicht vor.
Geht weiter. Du kannst hier den Nachtgeocoin zum Beispiel anleuchten. Der müsste auch die Fledermaus, da dürfte auch irgendwas passieren. Die Augen oder sowas müssten eigentlich, oder? Tut der was? Nee, man kann aber natürlich auch Koordinaten mit UV-Farbe irgendwo hinschreiben. Und das funktioniert natürlich auch tagsüber.
Das ist natürlich cool.
Aber nachts ist das natürlich wirkungsvoller. Oder in Bunkern ist das natürlich ganz gut. Also an Orten, wo es sowieso dunkel ist. Da ist das natürlich prädestiniert. Und es hilft aber natürlich auch Menschen abzuhalten. Also Muggles zum Beispiel abzuhalten bei einem Multi-Cache. Die finden halt vielleicht ein paar Stationen zufällig, wissen dann aber nicht, dass du bei einer bestimmten Station eine UV-Lampe brauchst, weil sie ja das Listing nicht gelesen haben. Und da steht dann vielleicht als Hinweis drin, hier mit UV-Licht suchen. Das wissen sie dann nicht und dann kommen sie natürlich nicht mehr weiter und können halt dann auch folglich den Cash nicht muggeln.
Hihi, so ein Muggelfilter.
Und, funktioniert? Ist der 5er echt?
Ist der neue 5-Euro-Schein. Ich bin überrascht, wie wenig UV-Aktivität der hat. Ist das schon länger so irgendwie?
Ich hab das nicht so verpasst. Die Alten sind hier irgendwie ein bisschen... Ich krieg von Geld scheinen immer nur mit, dass die immer fälschungssicher sind, aber immer noch fälschungssicherer werden.
Offensichtlich scheint UV nicht unbedingt eine der Schlüsseltechnologien zu sein, hier für die zukünftige Fälschungssicherheit, weil, wenn du selber mal vergleichen möchtest, der alte 10er und der neue 5er. Das ist natürlich cool, aber das finde ich auch wieder, das finde ich geil, weil das ist natürlich auch, UV-Licht ist so eine ganz einfache Technologie, mit der man so einen extra Layer einschalten kann, der erst mal so nicht offensichtlich ist. Genau wie auch dieser Digital-Layer, der so dazukommt.
Ja, ich habe das mal gemacht bei einer, sind die für mich?
Ach nee.
Die sind eh nicht echt, die UV-Prüfung halt. Du kannst froh sein, wenn ich damit nicht zur Bank gehe.
Da kannst du eh nichts mit anfangen. Das ist nur für Experten.
Ich habe das ja mal gemacht. Bei einer Zugfahrt habe ich mal mein Smartphone vor mich gelegt und habe mir mal in der Live-Karte anzeigen lassen, an wie vielen Geocaches ich gerade vorbeifahre. Das hat mir echt wehgetan. Das war echt schlimm.
Wieso?
Na ja, so alle zwei Minuten schwupp schon wieder an 50 Geocaches vorbeigefahren. Das ist echt schlimm, weil man möchte die ja eigentlich finden. Das ist halt auch doof mit der Bahn. Mit der Bahn kann man halt Schächgeo-Caching. Also nicht auf Reisen. Oder du musst das halt sehr gut planen oder wie auch immer.
Dazu gibt es Notbremsen.
Jeder wie er will.
Ich gebe dir jetzt mal hier deine Coins wieder, bevor ich die noch vergesse.
Ja, genau.
Aber jetzt haben wir im Prinzip das Geocacher-Besteck, das haben wir jetzt auch genannt. Also abgesehen jetzt von der Schatztruhe mit den Coins. Braucht man ein kleines Heftchen?
Also brauchst du auf jeden Fall einen GPS und einen Stift. Damit kannst du erstmal los. Fertig. Taschenlampe war jetzt bei mir halt das nächste, weil eben auch mal Nachtcache machen oder eben hilft einfach allgemein, mal in dunkle Ecken reinleuchten und so weiter. Und ich hab jetzt eben beschlossen, also das würde ich so als Grundausrüstung nehmen. UV-Lampe gehört für meine Begriffe schon eher zur EGCA, zur erweiterten Geocacher-Ausrüstung. Da gehören aber auch noch andere Dinge dazu.
Ist das dein Speak oder ist das tatsächlich Cacher-Talk?
Da gibt es auch noch andere Dinge, zum Beispiel Leitern gehören zur EGCA, Warthosen, Gummistiefel, Spiegel, manchmal sind die Koordinaten an Stationen so hingeschrieben, dass du die nur im Spiegel ablesen kannst.
Ich hatte ja hier vor ein paar Ausgaben auch das Thema Höhlenforschung.
Ja, genau. Bestimmt. Sind dann halt wahrscheinlich auch T5er, weil du kannst nicht einfach jeden in eine Höhle reinjagen.
Dass man eine Viertelstunde irgendwie durch ein Schlammloch robben muss, durch so eine kleine Röhre dich durchgleiten lassen muss.
Da musst du halt schon wissen, was du tust irgendwo. Genauso wie auf Lost Places auch. Kann man ja auch ein bisschen gespalten sehen. Gab es auch schon Todesfälle dabei übrigens. Also Geocacher, die auf Lost Places unterwegs waren und dann auch tatsächlich gestorben sind.
Also Lost Places ist so alte Häuser, Fabriken, verfallenes Zeug, Ruinen, diese ganze Kategorie. Das ist natürlich generell nicht ganz ungefährlich.
Richtig, so sieht's aus.
Also don't try this at home.
Also zur T-Wertung zum Beispiel, Lost Places sollte meiner Ansicht nach eigentlich immer schon, nee, also 2,5, 3 würde ich mindestens ansetzen. Weil du musst dich halt schon sehr gut, du musst halt wissen, wo du hintrittst. Also mir ist das tatsächlich auch selber mal passiert. Ich war den ganzen Tag in einer Ruine auf Pora unterwegs. Wir haben wirklich 12 Stunden da Hardcore durchgecashed. Und ich war dann einfach übermüdet, ich konnte nicht mehr richtig sehen und ich bin in so ein Loch reingefallen. Es war auch schon dunkel. Meine Taschenbatterie war auch nicht mehr so gut. Ich konnte auch sozusagen vom Licht hin. Es war nicht tief, beziehungsweise ich bin, Gott sei Dank, ich bin auf die Betonkante geknallt, und zwar genau zwischen den Beinen. War nicht so doll. Und bin dann noch eins tiefer gerutscht, aber war halt mit den Beinen quasi aufgefangen und hat mir dabei eine ganz veritable Rippenprellung zugezogen. Also war ich erst mal ein paar Wochen außer Gefecht.
Und Schuhwerk braucht man natürlich auch ordentliches, weil sich mal ein Nagel eintritt oder Scherben oder was weiß ich. Das ist auf jeden Fall so Outdoor sein. Da sind wir jetzt wieder bei dem Punkt, weil irgendwie bei diesem ganzen Geocaching versucht man die ganze Zeit nachzuvollziehen, was der Reiz ist. Das ist sehr offensichtlich nach dem, was wir jetzt alles besprochen haben, dass jetzt kein Reizmangel an sich vorhanden. Weil man so halbwegs so ein bisschen den Spaß und Abenteuer verknüpfen will mit draußen sein. Und das hat ja auch so ein bisschen was, auch so ein bisschen so ähnlich, wie jetzt mit diesem Ingress-Spiele waren. Ein Grund finden, rauszugehen. Grund finden, auch Orte aufzusuchen, die man sonst wahrscheinlich so nicht aufsuchen würde. Einfach auch um seine Welt mal ein bisschen anders kennenzulernen. Das mag zum Beispiel auch der Reiz bei diesen Lost Places sein. Aber halt auch irgendwelche Waldwege, Wanderwege überhaupt erstmal zu betreten. Sonst kommt man ja irgendwie nicht dazu.
Ja, also zum Beispiel als Jeremy Irish auf der Cebit war, da wurde ich vorher angesprochen, ob ich ein bisschen helfen kann bei der Vorbereitung, denn die vom, ich glaube, Bitkom, die das organisiert haben, die wollten gerne, dass da ein paar Geocaches auf dem Cebit-Gelände liegen und haben das ja ganz schlau angestellt, nicht einfach welche hinlegen, sondern jemanden aus der Szene finden, mit dem versuchen, was Lustiges zu machen. Und ich hatte dann einen Cache gemacht, auf dem Cebit-Gelände gibt es ja diesen großen Mosaikbrunnen, der da so langsam vor sich hin verfällt, bei diesem auffälligen Turm. Da lagen halt lauter von diesen Mosaikstein rum und ich habe mir da halt welche mitgenommen, die da sowieso vor sich hin zerfallen sind, habe daraus einen Deckel gebastelt, habe unten drunter eine Dose gemacht und die halt direkt neben dem Brunnen, also als Fortsetzung des Mosaiks an der Seite sozusagen in Boden versenkt. Und das als Cache zu finden. Und zusammen mit Jeremy Irish haben wir dann eben eine Ausgabe von dem Cache-Talk gemacht. Also mit dem zusammen übers Gelände und haben halt diese Caches gesucht. Ich gucke gerade, das war der Cache-Talk vom 3. März 2011.
Nummer?
Nummer, Nummer, Nummer, 125. Geocaching mit Jeremy auf der CeBit. Und da ist es mir tatsächlich passiert, da ist auch ein Bild, da suchen wir auch gerade diesen, also ich und Jeremy Irish suchen da diesen Cache. Also ich stand da mit Jeremy Irish und mit dem Mönch, der den Cache-Talk macht. Wir standen zu dritt da, er mit dem Mikrofon und sprachen auf Englisch. Und ich stand quasi, also mein linker Fuß war 3 cm neben meinem Cache. Jeremy Irish hat den schon gefunden, wir hatten ihn schon wieder zurückgelegt. Und dann kommt ein Geocacher an und bückt sich genau neben mir nach diesem Cache. Was ich völlig daneben finde, weil normalerweise soll man ja unauffällig cashen, damit eben nicht Muggles auf die Idee kommen, den Cache kaputt zu machen.
Verstehe, als ich schon mal ein bisschen daneben bin, direkt neben dem Gründer der ganzen Bewegung.
Ja, und neben dem Auna von dem Cache auch noch. Völlig daneben. Und dann habe ich also dem Podcast unterbrochen. Also Mönch hat weiter aufgenommen, er ging dann mit, aber das Gespräch mit Jeremy Eilish unterbrochen. Und habe dann diesen Geocacher angesprochen. Ich habe dann gesagt, sagen Sie mal Entschuldigung, was machen Sie hier neben meinen Füßen? Und dann hat er erstmal völlig ertappt, so, hier sind andere Leute, ich bin ja gar nicht alleine hier. Ich meine, er hat mir ein bisschen leid getan. Aber ich habe dann ihn wirklich auf Englisch angesprochen, habe gesagt, das gibt es doch gar nicht. Wir sind hier irgendwie zu Besuch, wir machen hier einen Podcast, das ist hier eine Live-Aufnahme, und Sie greifen einfach hier neben meine Füße. Und dann hat er aber auch tatsächlich den nächsten Fauxpas gleich geliefert und sagte, ja, ich suche einen Geocache. Und dann habe ich ihn natürlich erstmal gefragt, wie jetzt Sie suchen Geocache, wollen Sie mich verarschen oder was? Also ich meine, Sie greifen hier neben meine Füße und jetzt sagen Sie mir auch noch, Sie suchen hier irgendwas. Hören Sie mal, ich stand da, da ist nichts. Und dann habe ich den halt tatsächlich mal so 10 Minuten... Nein, ich habe den einfach hochgenommen. Ja, also Geocaching, das ist so ein Hobby und so. Und da sucht man halt so Dosen und da sind Doc-Bücher drin. Und ich so, wieder sucht man Dosen. Das können Sie mir noch nicht erzählen. Wollen Sie mir erzählen, dass irgendwelche Leute einfach Dosen in die Landschaft legen und andere Leute auch noch so blöd sind und die suchen das? Wo ist denn der Spaß dabei? Weil du ja auch sagst, wo ist denn der Spaß dabei? Und dann sagt er, ja, nee, das ist ganz toll. Er hat auch so ein bisschen leuchtende Augen gekriegt und das ist super. Ja, man kommt da an Orte, wo man vorher gar nicht hingehen würde und das ist total spannend und man findet die auch nicht immer gleich. Dann hab ich auch gesagt, das ist jetzt nicht Ihr Ernst. Sie wollen mir jetzt nicht erzählen, das sind irgendwie zehntausende erwachsene Menschen in der Weltgeschichte hier mit GPS-Device, nur um so eine Dose zu finden, wo ein Streifen Papier drin ist und da schreiben die ihren Namen drauf. Das glaub ich einfach nicht. Das glaub ich einfach nicht. Ich hab's dann irgendwann aufgedöst. Ich hab dann gesagt, übrigens, wir machen hier gerade einen Geocaching-Podcast. Das ist Jeremy Irish hier, der Gründer von Geocaching. Hallo gesagt, hat er sich auch voll gefreut. Ich hab Jeremy Irish getroffen. Guck mal, hat er dann hier so einen Jeremy Irish Travel Bug bekommen. Den gibt's dann nur von ihm. Und dann hat er sich natürlich auch gefreut.
Also er wusste auch, wer er ist sozusagen.
Nee, das wusste er nicht. Das war für ihn jetzt richtig super Jackpot.
Naja, ich meine, man geht los und sucht irgendwie nach einer Dose und findet Probin Hinte.
Also bei dem Cash Talk gibt es dann auch hier den Kommentar. Also diese Regine, wie sie die schwäbischen Casher durch den Kakao zieht, echt böse, ja. Ja, das war vielleicht ein bisschen böse, aber ich weiß.
Hier steht hinten drauf The Founder. Ist das jetzt ein Witz hier mit diesem Founder-Geonome-Project?
Nee, also er ist ja Gründer, Founder.
Ja, aber warum steht hier Geonome?
Weil das ein Gnome ist.
Ja, aber der Witz findet jetzt nur innerhalb dieses Dings statt. Es gibt jetzt nicht noch irgendwie Gnome.
Ich vermute, es gibt noch andere solche Geonome von anderen Foundern. Und du kannst halt alle zusammensammeln, wenn du das willst. Was dich noch interessieren könnte, es gibt übrigens auch Webcam-Caches. Ja, da gehst du irgendwo hin, wo eine Webcam Bilder aufnimmt. Und um den Cache zu loggen, musst du dann das von der Webcam aufgenommene Bild in das Log, also in das Listing reinladen, wo du auch drauf bist. Und damit hast du dann einen Webcam-Cache gelockt.
Muss das dann der Owner dann irgendwie noch abnehmen, bevor das gilt? Oder was heißt man muss? Also ich meine, wenn ich das nicht mache, kann ich ja trotzdem sagen, ich hab den gefunden.
Naja, du musst halt auf dem Bild erkennbar sein. Daran sieht man ja, dass du da warst. Also als Owner siehst du ja, aha, das ist auch wirklich der Webcam-Ausschnitt. Kannst ja nicht irgendein Bild machen, sondern es muss ja von der Webcam sein.
Ja gut, aber wenn ich jetzt überhaupt so einen ganz normalen Tradi-Cache suche und finde, dann habe ich den so im Wald irgendwo gefunden, keiner guckt zu, dann gehe ich danach auf die Webseite und sage, habe ich gefunden.
Ja, das hättest du wohl gerne. Tatsächlich gab das mal ein Geocaching-Troll, der hat genau das gemacht. Der hat, weiß ich nicht, innerhalb von wirklich Rekordzeit, also ist sozusagen ein Profil aufgefallen, der in der Berliner Geocaching-Szene, von einem Geocacher, der alle Caches in Berlin plötzlich hatte. Ja, also es schaffen selbst alt eingesessene Geocacher nicht. Und hat man halt rausgefunden, das war tatsächlich ein Geocaching-Troll, der hat einfach in alle Listings reingeschrieben, dass er den gefunden hätte. Und das Schöne an dem war, und deswegen wurde das auch kontrovers diskutiert, der hat tatsächlich richtig individuelle, fantasievolle, einzelne Logs geschrieben. Das muss man sich mal vorstellen, das sind ja über, weiß ich nicht, tausend, tausendfünfhundert whatever Geocaches in Berlin. Also eine sehr stattliche Anzahl. Und er hat tatsächlich für jeden Cache ein individuelles Found-Log reingeschrieben. Ja, wenn man ein bisschen faul ist und der Cache nicht so besonders war, dann schreibt man, ja, gut gefunden, dfdc, danke für den Cache. Wenn Cache halt richtig schön war, also kannst du zum Beispiel mal auf mein Profil gehen. Und man hat da echt Spaß gehabt und der Oner hat den auch liebevoll gemacht. Und man ist vielleicht durch mehrere Stationen durch oder so. Dann schreibt man schon gerne mal ein bisschen mehr. So, und du kannst mal da auf Geocaches gehen, genau. Und kannst mal all Geocache finds. So, dann habe ich zum Beispiel den Bademeister von Liebsten gemacht. Wenn du da mal hinklickst.
Das ist jetzt der Name des Caches.
Genau. Das ist ein Premium-Member-Only, deswegen siehst du jetzt von dem nicht das Listing.
Was unterscheidet hier die normale Membership und die Premium-Membership?
Genau, das siehst du hier gerade schön aufgelistet. Also Basic ist halt kostenfrei, Premium kostet 30 Dollar im Jahr. Weil die Plattform ist ja eigentlich werbefrei. Und die haben aber trotzdem Kosten für Server und Entwicklungsarbeit.
Also ein Premium-Modell.
Ja, aber ein brauchbares, wie ich finde. Manche Leute sagen halt, also der Cash-Owner kann sagen, ob sein Cash Premium Only sein soll. Und manche machen das eben, um damit quasi so eine Art Vandalismus vorzubeugen. Das ist so diese Homo economicus-Idee, dass Menschen für etwas, wofür sie zahlen, dann mehr Achtung davor haben.
Das ist sicherlich auch nachweisbar.
Nee, das macht kaum einen Unterschied. Es gibt immer Sohne und Sohne. Also es gibt immer Gruppmotoriker bei den Geocachern. Die hast du einfach überall. Die machen einfach alles kaputt, gewollt oder nicht. Auch wenn sie bezahlen. Das ist für ein Kind. Und 30 Dollar im Jahr ist jetzt auch nicht so was, wo du...
Aber das ist schon mal eine Hürde, über die man springen muss. Das heißt, das Beispiel kann ich jetzt gerade mal nicht abrufen.
Nee, sonst hab ich jetzt nicht so schöne Logs geschrieben.
Also aber man schreibt was, was halbwegs glaubwürdig ist. Wo man's gefunden hat oder wie man's gefunden hat.
Also dass man einen Cache gefunden hat, kann der ohne nachprüfen, weil man sich in das Logbuch eingetragen hat. Also man darf einen Cache nur als Found loggen, wenn man sich auch in das Logbuch reingeschrieben hat oder seinen Stempel reingetragen hat.
Das heißt, jeder Cache enthält eigentlich immer so ein Buch.
Genau. Außer es ist eben zum Beispiel ein Webcam-Cache, dann ist eben der Nachweis, dass du dort warst, dieses Webcam-Foto, wo du dann drauf bist. Genau.
Soll ich so einen Webcam-Cache hier auch leicht finden?
Wenn du suchst, die haben so ein kleines Webcam-Symbol. Genau.
Also sozusagen ein expliziter Typ, der hier so schon auch Teil des Systems ist. Genau. Wo wir jetzt gerade hier bei diesem Premium-Membership, Tra-la-la, Plattform, Abhängigkeiten etc. reden, du hast ja vorhin schon erwähnt, es gibt noch ein Open Cache, heißt das richtig?
Open Caching, genau. Das heißt, D, E, F, R, P, L, E, N, also für die unterschiedlichen Länder, in denen das Open Caching gemacht wird. Ich sage das deswegen so deutlich, weil Garmin wollte ja auch mal eine eigene Geocaching-Plattform anbieten, die hieß dann lustigerweise auch Open Caching. Was ich ein bisschen verwirrend finde, weil es ist eigentlich der Garmin Caching und nicht Open Caching. Und die hatten auch als Logo so eine Mischung aus dem Logo von geocaching.com und opencaching.de, was ich auch schon irgendwie so... Ja, also irgendwie komisch. Nee, opencaching.de wird halt von Leuten gemacht, die auch mit manchen Regelungen bei GroundSpeak nicht so zufrieden sind. Und zum Beispiel gibt es bei opencaching.de keine Abstandsregelungen, die ja manchmal auch echt ein bisschen albern ist, weil die Station trotz... Also die Begründung für die Abstandsregelung ist, man soll ja die Caches finden können, die sollen nicht zu nah beieinander liegen. Jetzt ist, wenn man in Amerika ist, sind 160 Meter natürlich schon relativ nah beieinander, aber wenn man sich hier in Berlin bewegt, dann sind 160 Meter ja... Also da liegen ja Welten dazwischen. Das ist ja fast schon ein anderer Kiez. Das ist ja eine Weltreise eigentlich. Genau. Und das Lustige ist auch, das ist so ein bisschen subversiv daran, ist natürlich auch, dass du natürlich an die gleichen Koordinaten, wo auch schon ein Geocaching kommt, also im Groundspeed-Cache liegt, kannst du natürlich auch jetzt noch eine andere Dose hinlegen, das ist dann aber ein Open Caching. Das ist dann halt da gelistet. Das kann einem durchaus passieren, dass man in hoch frequentierte Orte kommt und da liegen dann halt mal fünf Dosen von verschiedenen Plattformen. Und damit ist natürlich diese Abstandsregel auch völlig obsolet. Das ist natürlich dann ein Unsinn.
Nutzt du aber jetzt nicht als Plattform?
Ich habe das mal gemacht. Ich habe auch, glaube ich, alle meine Groundspeed-Caches auch auf Open Caching gelistet, damit die dort auch gelockt werden können. Ich habe da aber schon lange nicht mehr hingeguckt. Das ist mir ehrlich gesagt zu kompliziert. Ich habe auch, also ich hätte dann auch eine Statistik, die halt sowohl meine Open Caches als auch meine Geocaches listet, wie viel ich dann insgesamt gefunden habe und welche und so. Und als das für mich aktuell war, habe ich mich damit schwergetan. Mittlerweile gibt es ja, glaube ich, auch einfachere Sachen, wie auch immer, ist bei mir ein bisschen eingeschlafen. Hier, ich habe auch noch ein Gadget für dich zurückgeben.
Gadgets hin und her.
Mein Favoritpunkt möchte ich auch gerne wieder haben.
Wo du das Wort gerade fallen lässt, Statistiken. Das ist natürlich hier auch ein interessantes, interessante Datensenke, diese ganze Caching- und Personenaktivität. Und Leute befinden sich zu Zeitpunkt X an Personenposition Y. Gibt es da irgendwelche Aktivitäten, das mal zu visualisieren oder sonst wie zu analysieren?
Du kannst noch mal auf mein Profil gehen, bitte.
Dann gehen Sie auf das Profil, mach ich doch glatt. The Frühtau. Genau.
Und dann findest du ganz rechts den Reiter Statistik.
Ich hoffe, der ist jetzt für mich auch zugänglich hier.
Nee, siehst du auch nicht. Schade, schade, schade, schade.
Du musst hier erst Premium klicken.
Ja, aber dann gehen wir mal woanders hin. Dann gehen wir nämlich mal auf die Seite projectgc.com. Das ist eigentlich so das... Also ich finde, mir fehlt da noch einiges, aber ich glaube, das ist erst mal so ein kleines Nirvana für Daten nerds. Unique Caches in Germany. Aktive Caches in Deutschland 299.150. Wenn man Deutschland leer cashen will, da hat man schon zu tun. Da musst du so knapp 300.000 Caches finden.
300.000?
299.150, ne?
Ja, davon auch.
Und 10.856 sind im Moment disabled.
Also nur ein geringer Teil davon?
Nein, nicht davon, sondern...
Ach so, nicht davon, aber okay.
Genau, am Ende der Reihe haben wir noch einen Total. Es sind 503.657 Geocaches für Deutschland gelistet. Davon sind 299.000 aktiv, knapp 11.000 im Moment disabled und 193.600 sind schon archiviert. Also die gibt es nicht mehr.
Okay, aber ein Großteil...
Es gibt nicht mal archivierte Caches, auch wenn tatsächlich die Dosen noch da sind. Das gibt es zum Beispiel auch. Es gibt Leute, die haben sich darauf spezialisiert, archivierte Caches aufzusuchen und loggen die dann auch noch weiter und tragen ihren Found-Log auch auf der Webseite ein. Da gibt es auch so ein paar Geheimtipps. Also wenn man will, dass ein Geocache tatsächlich nur von sehr wenigen Menschen gefunden wird, dann ist ein guter Tipp, den zu archivieren und unter der Hand zu streuen, dass er ja trotzdem noch aktiv ist.
So, interessanter finde ich ja hier die Zahlen da rechts, nämlich die aktiven Kescher. Die Wochenstatistik, die reißt hier gerade so ein bisschen raus, aber das mag auch sehr wetterabhängig sein, wenn man das jetzt so im Jahresvergleich hat.
Herbstferien sind zu Ende?
Im letzten Monat 108.540 aktive Kescher. Auf welche Daten bezieht sich denn das jetzt? Schon auf geocaching.com? Kommt man da so ohne Weiteres ran?
Ja, das war lange Zeit problematisch. Groundspeak saß ja ziemlich auf den Daten, ich glaube, bis zu vor zwei oder drei Jahren auch ungefähr. Da gab es auch, glaube ich, eine Restriction. Man konnte selbst als Premium-Member, glaube ich, nicht mehr als eine bestimmte Anzahl Listings in einer Minute abrufen, weil danach war der Verdacht groß, dass da gerade ein Bot kommt und scraped. Das war natürlich sehr ärgerlich, weil dann ging das ja auch los mit den Smartphones und den Geocaching-Apps und so weiter. Und dann haben sich halt die App-Entwickler bei Groundspeak beschwert, weil damit kommt es dann natürlich nicht weiter. Die App meldet sich dann dort an und zieht die Daten. Und schwupp, funktioniert nichts mehr, weil da diese Restriction greift. Dann haben sie halt einen API aufgesetzt. Und das hat ein paar Dinge auf jeden Fall schon mal erleichtert. Auch für solche Statistikseiten zum Beispiel. Aber es gibt trotzdem oft noch nicht angesagte Änderungen im API, die dann in der App erst mal nicht durchgreifen.
Persönliche Probleme.
Genau.
Hier gibt es noch eine schöne Matrix, die die ganzen Caches, die es gibt, aufspaltet nach Difficulty und Terrain. Also sozusagen so eine 1 bis 5 Difficulty auf der Y und 1 bis 5 Terrain. Oder andersherum, nicht Terrain.
Auf der X.
Auf der X, genau. Leider nur mit Zahlen. Jetzt wäre hier mal eine schöne Heatmap ganz interessant. Aber wenn ich das so richtig sehe, der Großteil befindet sich so im Schwierigkeitsbereich von zwischen 1 und 2. Wenig überraschend. Und dann halt auch so im Terrainbereich von 1 bis 2,5. Also klar, umso schwerer, höher, weiter, umso seltener. Ja, aber da geht doch bestimmt noch mehr, oder?
Ja, die haben ja auch oben noch ein paar Navigationspunkte. Maps zum Beispiel, Top Finders, Top Heiders. Da hast du zum Beispiel Top-FTFer.
Ah ja, schauen wir nochmal bei den Freunden.
Wer macht die meisten FTFs?
Jetzt will die Webseite nicht reagieren. Naja, auf jeden Fall findet statt, es gibt eine API, aber ist alles noch ein bisschen schwierig bei geocaching.com. Das wäre natürlich eine große Chance für Open Caching da maximal Warten anzubieten, oder?
Die machen das im Prinzip auch gar nicht so blöd. Es gibt ja auch noch andere Plattformen, wie extremecaching und was weiß ich. Also bei extremecaching würde ich davon ausgehen, dass die von der kleinen Community leben, wenn es eine kleine Special-Interest-Gruppe anspricht. Die haben auch T-Wertungen bis sieben. Ich habe es mir selber noch nicht ganz genau angeguckt. Da ist es natürlich gut, wenn das Klettern und gefährliches Zeug ist. Es ist auch gut, wenn das wenige Leute machen. Bei Open Caching habe ich immer das Problem, da sind einfach zu wenige. Du findest zu wenig Caches, da wo du gerade bist, da ist Groundspeak einfach der Platzhirsch sozusagen. Plus, die Caches müssen ja auch entstandgehalten werden. Und wenn du da nicht Reviewer hast, die da hinterher sind, oder die Community auch groß genug ist, dass du halt mitkriegen kannst, der Cache ist tatsächlich auch gerade nicht mehr da. Oder da ist auch wirklich irgendwas nicht in Ordnung und nicht ein Reviewer sagt, du hör mal, dein Cache steht jetzt seit drei Monaten auf Needs Maintenance, du machst hier nichts, wenn sich in den nächsten drei Wochen hier nichts tut oder ich keine Nachricht kriege, dann archiviere ich den, weil andere Leute auch noch einen Cache legen wollen, dann macht das Feld frei sozusagen. Dann macht das Cachen auch keinen Spaß. Also, da hat GroundSpeak einfach da wirklich diesen unglaublichen Massenvorteil. Die Anzahl der Caches, die Lebhaftigkeit der Community, auch die Durchmischung der Community und unterschiedlichen Menschen, unterschiedliche Caches. International. Das siebt halt einfach alles davon.
Was meinst du jetzt mit hier, meinst du das hier mit Extreme Caching? Ja, genau. Extrem Caching, also es gibt deutsche Community.
T5 und Lost Plays Community.
Ah, verstehe.
Bunkerhöhen, Untergrund, Felsenbäume.
Nur die Harten kommen in Garten.
Die Harten kommen in ganzen Garten.
Ja, verstehe.
Nur die Harten kommen im Bunker.
Gibt es noch andere Communities, die vielleicht noch eine Rolle spielen könnten?
Besser Cacher sind noch ganz schön. Das finde ich auch eine schöne Idee. Caches jenseits von Parkbank und Telefonzelle. Die nehmen Caches auf Empfehlung. Da steckt eine Forumsengine dahinter. Wenn dir halt ein Cache besonders gut gefällt und du findest, der sollte halt dort gelistet werden, dann machst du halt dafür einen Forumseintrag. Wenn du keinen Bock hast, dich da anzumelden, dann schickst du einfach eine Mail an die Betreiberin.
Das dockt aber dann an das normale geocaching.com an?
Ja, kann aber auch OC sein.
Ach so, ein Meta-System für beide Systeme. Es ist nicht nochmal ein komplett eigenes System, sondern nur so eine Auswahl.
Genau, du kannst auch mal hier auf so einen Icon draufklicken auf der Karte.
Qualitätscaching sozusagen.
Da siehst du einmal hast du jetzt aus der Karte raus einen Link entweder zum GC-Listing. Open Caching hat dann OC-Listing. Oder du kannst zum Forum-Thread gehen von dem Cache. Wo du dann sehen kannst, wer hat den angegeben.
Der Cache liegt in einem aktiv bejagten Gebiet. Ich bitte euch ausdrücklich den Cache auf keinen Fall bei Dämmerung oder Dunkelheit.
Also wie alle Menschen, die im Wald was machen wollen, Hund ausführen, Mountainbiken, wandern, Pilze suchen, sind natürlich auch die Geocacher der natürliche Feind des Jägers. Echt wahr?
Ist das jetzt ja ein Mystery-Cache, wo ich jetzt gerade drauf gestoßen bin?
Nein, es ist ein Multi, aber es kann sein, dass diese Zahlen durch irgendwas ersetzt werden sollen, was du im Laufe des Multis findest. Oder dass du eine Anweisung findest, was du mit diesen Zahlen machen sollst.
Was ich richtig verstehe, ist, dass hier eine recht spielerische Cache hier auch, wo hier eine kleine Geschichte erfunden wird.
Also ein guter Cache lebt von unterschiedlichen Sachen. Also zum Beispiel dieser, den ich gelegt habe, auf den ich auch ein kleines bisschen stolz bin, weil es der zweitmeist gefafte Geocache von Berlin ist. Knapp 1300 FaF-Punkte hat er jetzt, glaube ich, bald. Also schon fast so viele FaF-Punkte, wie ich Geocaches gefunden habe.
Und der heißt wie?
Der heißt Touristic Spot Hackeische Höfe. Und der lebt halt zum Beispiel in seiner Beliebtheit, also das ist in dem Fall wirklich ein Zufallstreffer, lebt ja einfach davon, dass er erstens an einem vielbesuchten Ort ist. Also da kommen auch viele Geocacher einfach vorbei. Hackeische Höfe. Und zweitens lebt er tatsächlich davon und kriegt so viele FaF-Points dafür, dass der völlig offensichtlich ist. Also den sieht jeder, den sehen auch alle Geocacher, die denken aber nicht, dass da ein Cache drin ist. Und außerdem musst du noch dazu eine kleine Klettereinlage machen. Also viel mehr möchte ich jetzt nicht spoilern. Das musst du dich als Cacher auch erstmal trauen. Also du musst sozusagen bei diesem Cache ganz bewusst dieses getarnte Caching hinter dir lassen. Und ich habe ganz viele Log-Einträge, wo Leute sagen, wir waren schon fünfmal hier, da waren immer so viele Muggels und wir haben uns nicht getraut. Und dann haben wir aber doch jetzt einfach mal zugegriffen und das war so toll und wir hatten ein super Cache-Erlebnis.
Ist doch was für den Nerd von heute. Ja, was macht noch einen guten Cache aus?
Ich habe zum Beispiel mal einen gefunden, Multi. Der hatte ein langweiliges Listing, war auch sonst nicht so dolle. Aber was an diesem Ding echt total geil war, da war bei jeder Station eine größere Dose und in dem Deckel von der Dose hatte der Cash-Owner immer mit Schlumpffiguren, die hat er da so mit Silikon oben an der Decke festgeklebt, hat da immer so eine Szene nachgestellt und immer in die Dose dann so einen kleinen Zettel reingelegt und so eine kleine Geschichte dazugeschrieben, was dem Schlumpfen gerade passiert. Das fand ich total geil. Das war einfach, das war so, so, so. Also ich habe mich gefragt, hat der ein Kind gemacht? Oder, keine Ahnung, das war so liebevoll, auch die Figuren so zusammengestellt und die Geschichte erzählt. Und es war wirklich, ich glaube, sieben oder acht Stationen, wo der solche kleinen Miniaturen Schlumpflandschaften da reingebaut hat. Das fand ich toll. Da habe ich einen Pfaffpunkt dafür vergeben, zum Beispiel. Nee, ich habe für zehn gefundenen Caches kriegst du einen Pfaffpunkt.
Ach, für gefundene Caches. Ach, Entschuldigung, ich hatte das. Aber hast du nicht, wie viel hast du denn gefunden?
Ich habe jetzt, glaube ich, 1300, irgendwas. Ja, 1311.
Also 130 Pfaffpunkte, die du vergeben kannst.
Genau. Und ganz viele habe ich schon verteilt. Im Moment darf ich, glaube ich, noch 29 oder 30 Pfaffpunkte vergeben.
Richtig, jeder sozusagen. Das ist schon ganz interessant, weil man automatisch quasi durch dieses System nur Pfaffs verteilt werden von Leuten, die es auch wirklich aktiv betreiben. Oder die Betrollung aktiv betreiben. Das könnte ich auch sein.
Oder manche Caches sind auch ganz einfach gemacht, ist aber eine super schöne Geschichte dazu. Oder bei Mysteries, das ist manchmal auch einfach nur eine Filmdose, die irgendwo liegt. Aber ein super interessantes Rätsel macht auch einen guten Cache aus. Bei Lost Places ist es natürlich schön, wenn dich ein Multi-Cache sehr zuverlässig über das Gelände führt. Wenn du dann vom Gelände runter kommst, also fertig bist, und du hast das Gefühl, du hast auch wirklich genau die Highlights mitgenommen. Also da hat auch jemand wirklich ganz genau die Punkte ausgesucht, wo es sich auch wirklich lohnt, hinzugehen. Zum Beispiel der Cache, den wir auf Prora gemacht haben, der hatte drei Teile. Der erste Teil bestand darin, dass man durch... Also Prora ist ja dieses langgezogene Kraft durch Freude da von Hitler, dieses längste Ferienheim, das längste Ferienheim der Welt. So Duplo-Ding irgendwie oder so. Da musstest du halt durch einen Gebäudeabschnitt, der ist halt so, weiß ich nicht, 100 Meter lang, 80 Meter lang, kann ich schlecht schätzen, aber so was um den Dreh, musstest du halt durch alle, weiß ich nicht, sechs Stockwerke durch, in jedes Zimmer reingucken und dann zufällige Graffitis finden, die halt im Listing abgebildet waren. Und davon glaube ich zehn oder zwölf Stück insgesamt. Ich meine, nun waren wir zu viert, wir haben uns aufgeteilt, wir haben halt gesagt, okay, zwei Leute laufen das ab, zwei Leute laufen das ab, dann können wir uns das teilen. Wir haben trotzdem wahnsinnig lange gebraucht. Und da fragt man sich schon, was ist der Mehrwert davon? Die Zimmer sahen alle gleich aus. Es war immer das gleiche Gebäude. Die Graffitis waren nicht alle jetzt besonders toll. Es hätte es auch getan, einfach zu sagen, okay, ihr sucht nur drei Graffitis, eins davon findet ihr im Erdgeschoss, eins findet ihr irgendwo in der Mitte, eins findet ihr irgendwo ganz oben. Also es hätte einfach völlig gereicht, um den Charakter des Gebäudes zum Beispiel aufzunehmen, anstatt irgendwie stundenlang durch die immer gleichen Zimmer zu rennen und auf gut Glück da irgendeine Bilder zu finden.
Eigentlich braucht man so ein bisschen, mich erinnert das so ein bisschen an Veranstaltungsmanagement, wenn man sich so ein bisschen darüber Gedanken macht, wie man so ein Event wirklich erlebbar und wie soll ich sagen, lohnenswert macht für Teilnehmer.
Ja, spontan kommt einem das Wort User Experience in den Sinnen.
Ja, so könnte man es auch nennen. Aber gerade so im Sinne von, was ist noch spannend und was wiederholt sich, was diesen Schwierigkeitsgrad dann auch entsprechend anzupassen oder die Vielfalt richtig zu finden. Weil man eben leicht auch dann, gerade wenn man erstmal was ganz toll findet, so eine Idee schnell dazu tendiert, zu viel zu machen. Eigentlich müsste man seine Caches ja selber erstmal finden und feststellen, wie schwierig das eigentlich ist. Hast du das schon mal gemacht, dass du dir quasi deine Caches selbst erarbeitet hast, um nochmal festzustellen, ob sie gut designed sind?
Naja, das ist ja schwierig, weil man ist ja betriebsblind. Das ist wie, wenn du Software entwickelst. Du machst ja immer das, wofür sie da ist.
Ich glaube, wenn man einen guten Vortrag hält und den zumindest einmal in Realtime selber durcharbeitet, da fällt einem schon mal was auf.
Ja klar, wenn man aber gerade mal 18 Caches gefunden hat und möchte jetzt endlich mal selber einlegen, wenn man das gerade so ganz toll findet, dann denkt man auch, man hat was ganz Tolles gemacht. Und es ist ja auch gut, dass viele Caches da sind. Also ich würde das überhaupt nicht jetzt irgendwie verächtlich schmälern wollen oder so. Aber es ist schon verständlich, dass jemand, der nicht 1000 oder 2000 Caches gefunden hat, der im Listing liest so, das ist mein erster, als erster mal denkt, okay, also den kann ich jetzt schon mal, den muss ich nicht finden. Was man aber macht, ist, wenn man ein bisschen Anspruch hat und vielleicht auch gerade, wenn es ein Multicache ist, man lässt Beta-Teams durchgehen.
Dass man andere Leute testen lässt.
Genau. Also ich habe zum Beispiel mit einem Bekannten von mir einen Motorrad-Nachtcache gelegt. Und da waren wir bei vielen Stationen ganz unsicher, ob unsere Ideen so aufgehen.
Was heißt Motorrad-Nachtcache? Also dass man ein Motorrad braucht?
Du kannst ihn auch mit dem Auto machen. Aber du solltest ihn motorisiert machen, weil der geht, glaube ich, über 80 oder 90 Kilometer insgesamt. Also du bist die Nacht schon gut beschäftigt. Und du brauchst auch das Fernlicht für die Reflektoren. Genau. Also schon die Idee, dass du dich da mit einem Gefährt durchbewegst. Und da waren wir ganz unsicher, auch wegen Verkehrssituationen und so weiter. Und da sind wir mit einem Beta-Team durch. Und da war ein Geocacher dabei, der Polizist ist. So was ist auch immer sehr schön, wenn man solche Leute hat. Am Bahnhof Lichtenberg gab es zum Beispiel auch schon mal falschen Alarm. Weil Geocacher sind ja ganz gefährliche Bombenleger. Und es ist halt ganz gut, wenn da irgendwo so ein paar Polizisten dabei sind, und die sagen, du, lass mal, ist schon okay. Die Kollegen sagen, das ist kein Bombenleger, sondern das ist ein Geocacher und dann wissen die das auch irgendwann. Und dann ist es auch gut. Also ich finde nicht, dass deswegen Polizisten jeden dummen Geocacher auch dulden müssen. Also ich kann es gut verstehen, dass das eine Nervosität auch macht. Aber es ist natürlich auch gut, wenn da eine gewisse ruhige Hand, eine gewisse Besonnenheit regiert und nicht da gleich der sofort der große Aufschrei losgeht sozusagen.
Also Polizisten überproportional vertreten?
Nee, kann man nicht sagen. Also Geocaching-Szene gerade, also was jetzt eben so bei GroundSpeak so ist, ist wirklich extrem gut durchmischt. Also auch wenn du zu den Stammtischen gehst, du findest wirklich alles. Also sämtliche Berufsschichten, sämtliche Charaktere, alles.
Es gibt keine Berufe, die jetzt irgendwie eine gewisse Häufigkeit...
Nee, kann man so nicht sagen. Also du musst natürlich Gadget-affin sein und irgendwie Internet-affin.
Ich dachte mir nur gerade, wenn man so bei der Spurensicherung arbeitet, ist natürlich so Geocaching sicherlich auch ein ganz guter Sport.
Da hätte ich gerne mal das Thema mehr Geocaches legen. Um auf den Motorrad nachcash zurückzukommen, der Polizist jedenfalls, der hat einige Bemerkungen gehabt. Der hat das auch irgendwann abgebrochen, den Beta-Test. Er hat gesagt, ich mache das nicht mehr, das ist mir zu gefährlich. Das hat er uns auch gut begründet. Wir fanden das einsichtig und haben deswegen einfach den Cache noch mal umgebaut, um da die Gefahrenquellen einfach rauszunehmen.
Was war denn jetzt die Gefahrenquelle, die sich da aufgetan hat?
Also was wir zum Beispiel als ONA völlig unterschätzt hatten, ist so, dass du gerade bei einem Multi, wenn du dich so langsam dann dem Final näherst, du bist so vor Final und so, da kriegst du dann natürlich auch langsam Jagdfieber. So, ja, endlich hab ich die Dose und so. Genau, und das ist nämlich auch genau die Gefährlichkeit, weil du musst ja trotzdem dich verkehrsregelkonform verhalten. Wenn das auf dem Land ist, kann es halt passieren, dass du nicht mehr ganz so vorsichtig fährst, Stichwort Wildunfälle und so weiter. Und wenn du dann auch noch bestimmte Signale nicht deutlich identifizieren kannst, dann wird es natürlich nervig. Und da haben wir dann einfach dafür gesorgt, dass die Stationen einfach eindeutiger sind. Wir haben das im Listing auch noch mal deutlicher beschrieben, sodass du eine bessere Idee hast, wo du dann tatsächlich auch hin musst.
Dass man sich nicht nur auf Suchen konzentriert, sondern vielleicht dann auch noch mal ein bisschen auf den Verkehr.
Ja, so ein kleines bisschen ist ja nicht verkehrt.
Ja, das würde helfen.
Genau, genau. Und das war zum Beispiel wertvoll, weil wir waren da völlig betriebsbildend. Wir wussten ja, wo es hingeht. Wir sind die Strecke dreimal abgefahren, bis wir den Cash gelegt haben. Als wir den Cash gelegt haben, sind wir sie abgefahren. Danach sind wir noch zweimal die Strecke abgefahren, weil wir immer noch ein paar Sachen nachgebessert haben und ausgebessert. Dann haben wir drei Beta-Tests insgesamt gemacht, bis wir gesagt haben, okay, jetzt sind wir zufrieden. Bis alle gesagt haben, so ist es in Ordnung, so macht das Ding Spaß.
Was denken denn so die Förster, wenn da irgendwie die ganzen Geocacher da durch ihre Wälder ziehen?
Lustige Frage. Ich glaube, wirklich begeistert sind sie nicht. Ich bin vor kurzem bei einer Geocaching-Recherche in einem Forum für Landleute gelandet. Da hat sich ein Forstwirtschaftler gefragt, wie ist das denn mit Geocachern, die in den Bäumen rumklettern? Also, dass Nachtcaches schwierig sind, kann ich verstehen, wenn da Horden von Geo... Also ich übertreibe jetzt mal ein bisschen Horden von Geocachern mit... Also du hast ja gesehen, was das für Taschendampen sind. Da finde ich es schon, auch Naturschutzgebiete finde ich schon gut. Man bleibt vielleicht ein bisschen auf den Wegen. Das Wild dann auch, da sind die. Und dann sind sie aber nicht da und so. Ich glaube, man kann das schon in einer friedlichen Co-Existenz gestalten. Und es ist nicht gleich komplett verbieten. Aber man muss dann halt auch ein bisschen vernünftig sein.
Ich bereue auch vorhin meine Erwähnung des Höhlenforschungspodcasts. Wer sich dahingehört hat, der wird dann auch sich gemerkt haben, dass das nicht unbedingt die Orte sind, wo man jetzt irgendwelche Muggels durchschicken möchte, aber auch vielleicht keine erfahrenen Geocacher, sondern maximal die Höhlenforscher. Aber die wissen sich da ja auch selber zu helfen. Was mir eben gerade nochmal kam, gibt es da bestimmt auch immer mal wieder Leute, die so auf Ideen kommen werden. Das finde ich mit Garmin schon so ein bisschen der Versuch, im kommerziellen Interesse was Eigenes aufzubauen. Wenn ich mir überlege, Tourismus oder so, könnte sich unter Umständen auch durchaus gereizt sehen, da mal ein paar...
Also es gibt tatsächlich Unternehmen, die führen Geocaching-Touren an, zum Beispiel. Das ist für mich auch die persönliche Grenze, weil das denke ich noch, kann man noch machen. Was man da anbietet, ist ja nicht sozusagen das, was Groundspeak bietet, sondern ist ja die Dienstleistung so. Dass du quasi sagst, wir wissen die guten Caches. Und ihr findet sie halt auf jeden Fall, weil wir wissen ja, wo der Final ist. Ich meine, das ist ärgerlich. Du bist irgendwo 1500 Kilometer weg und du weißt genau, du kommst da entweder nie wieder in deinem Leben hin oder in drei Jahren vielleicht mal wieder und du fährst weg und du standest am Final und hast aber die Dose nicht gefunden. Das ist einfach echt ein scheiß Gefühl. Ja, du lachst. Also das finde ich noch gerade so in Ordnung. Und natürlich werden Leute, die sowas anbieten, auch ein Interesse daran haben, dass die Caches auch gut sind, dass die guten Caches auch gut bleiben, dass sie gut gewartet werden. Vielleicht nehmen sie dem ONA auch noch ein bisschen Wartungsarbeit ab und so weiter und so weiter.
Oder sie sind die ONA.
Oder sie sind die ONA oder wie auch immer. Was ich dagegen sehr schwierig finde, ist, wenn ein Tourismusverband, das habe ich schon gesehen, ich glaube hier in der Wachau, in Österreich, da gab es auf der Tourismusseite, hier, wir sind ein super interessantes Tourismusgebiet, wir haben auch schöne Geocaches. Und da waren so drei oder fünf Stück aufgelistet. Und die hatten aber noch nicht mal die ONA vorher gefragt. Und das finde ich nicht nur grenzwertig, weil die mit etwas werben, was ihnen nicht gehört. So prinzipiell erstmal. Sondern das finde ich auch grenzwertig, weil es Caches gibt, denen viel Publikum einfach nicht gut tut. Die können überleben und sind schön, weil die halt einmal in drei Monaten gefunden werden. Und sobald die mehr gefunden werden, ist es halt vorbei. Da hätten jetzt zum Beispiel...
Da werben die auch immer noch von, wenn ich das hier richtig sehe.
Und wenn da halt Cash-Owner slightly pissed sind, kann ich das sehr gut nachvollziehen.
Ich meine, ihr hättet jetzt erwartet, dass sie da vielleicht mal ihre eigenen Caches aufbauen.
Ja, das wird dann wieder schwierig, weil dann sind es Leute, die halt vielleicht eigentlich keine Geocacher sind. Da merkst du das an den Caches. Die sind halt einfach doof und langweilig. Also man braucht da schon ein bisschen Fingerspitzengefühl.
Na gut, aber man könnte das ja machen wie mit dir und der CeBIT. Wir gucken uns mal hier die Top Geocacher der Region irgendwie raus und fragen die mal, ob sie nicht mal Bocketten hier in der Gegend was zu implantieren. Vielleicht auch an Orten, die, sagen wir mal, etwas tourismusfester sind.
Glaube ich kaum, dass sich ein Owner für sowas hergeben würde, gerade wenn es ein Top Geocacher ist. Weil die Infrastruktur funktioniert ja. Also warum sollen Cash-Owner, der ein paar Super-Caches gelegt hat, es gibt zum Beispiel in Hessen gibt es die Helden, die haben, glaube ich, fünf von den zehn Top Ten favorisierten Geocaches in Hessen gelegt. Warum sollen die für einen Tourismusverband einen Cash legen?
Naja, ich denke jetzt nur so aus der Logik eines Tourismusverbandes.
Dann geht es nämlich weiter. Wer ist dann der Owner von dem Cash? Dann müsste der Tourismusverband auch angeben, dass er der Owner von dem Cash ist. Da spielt GroundSpeak natürlich nicht mehr mit. Logischerweise, weil die sagen, wir bieten nur eine Plattform an von Privatleuten für Privatleute. Deswegen halten wir das auch billig. Wir wollen auch, dass es einen breiten Sport bleibt. Wir wollen, dass jeder sich das im Groben erstmal leisten kann, dass jeder daran teilnehmen kann. Was ich auch gut finde. Also Geocaching ist wirklich eben durch alle Schichten gehender Breitensport. Und das soll es auch bleiben. Weil sonst, diese Vielfalt macht einfach auch Spaß. Dann gab es mal Werbeaktionen. Ich glaube mal hier Project Ape. Das war glaube ich für irgendeinen Film. Bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher. Die haben ein paar extra Caches rausgebracht. Das ist auch immer noch eine extra Geocache-Kategorie. Project Ape Caches, glaube ich. Und auch irgendwie ein paar Coins. Das funktionierte gut, weil die Caches gut gemacht waren und die Coins begehrt waren. Dann gab es vor einiger Zeit mal einen amerikanischen Outdoor-Shoe-Hersteller, Timberland. Ich glaube, die sind aus Amerika. Die haben sich für meine Begriffe maximal in die Nesseln gesetzt. Da habe ich auch hier mit dem Podpin mal einen Brujaha-Podcast drüber gemacht. Wie setzen sich kommerzielle Geocaching-Nutzungsversuche?
Der Podcast war über Marketing-Fails.
Ja, Social Media Marketing Fails insbesondere. Und die haben sowas gemacht. Die haben also in Parks, in europäischen Städten, ich glaube in Paris, London, Barcelona, Berlin und noch irgendwo haben sie jeweils fünf Caches pro Stadt ausgelegt. Es waren aber nicht die, sondern die Reviewer haben diese Caches ausgelegt. Und das lief unter dem Account der Schuhmacher oder sowas. Also es war überhaupt nicht ersichtlich, dass der Owner quasi eine kommerzielle Firma ist oder schon gar nicht, dass das eine Werbeaktion ist.
Die haben sich dann Reviewer ge-
Die haben GroundSpeak dafür bezahlt, dass GroundSpeak halt Reviewer, die ehrenamtlich arbeiten, gesagt hat, leg mal die Caches hin. Dann waren das nicht besonders schön gemachte Caches. Hier in Berlin waren drei von den fünf Tradis nach zwei Tagen auch gleich mal weg. Und da standen auch etliche Write-Notes von Leuten, die sich geärgert haben, dass sie quasi ihr Hobby machen und aber unfreiwillig in eine Werbeaktion reingerutscht sind, die als solche noch nicht mal gekennzeichnet war. Und dann kommt natürlich auch das dazu, also GroundSpeak ist mit manchen Dingen extrem pingelig. Du darfst zum Beispiel keine Links zu irgendwelchen Organisationen ins Listing setzen. Und das haben die so so obsessiv und konsequent durchgezogen, dass wir selbst für unsere Geocaching-Stammtische nicht den Link zu dem Restaurant oder zu der Kneipe in das Listing setzen dürfen, wo wir uns treffen. Wir geben ja aber die Namen an und wir geben ja auch die Koordinaten an. Also das ist einfach so, da denkst du echt so, man, Leute, geht's noch. Oder Abstandsregel. Wenn dann Cash in Berlin mal nur 155,6 Zentimeter statt 160, dann nee, wird nicht durchgelassen. Also da gibt es so etliche Dinge, wo du dich echt irgendwie so ein bisschen auch gegängelt fühlst. Und dann andererseits kommt aber so ein Unternehmen daher und zahlt mal irgendwie ordentlich was. Und dann sollen die ehrenamtlich arbeitenden Reviewer da auch noch die Arbeit machen. Die müssen ja dann auch warten. Also die sollen dann zu den zerstörten Caches gehen, sollen wieder neue hinlegen und so weiter. Man hat da sonst nichts zu tun.
Das Ding ist dann explodiert.
Also ich fand es völlig daneben. Also es gab Leute, die fanden es gut. Es gab Leute, die fanden es auch als Werbeaktion witzig. Jeder wie er will. Für meinen Geschmack waren da echt mehrere Grenzen überdeutlich überschritten.
Und heißt das, dass das so nicht noch mal passieren wird? Oder ist das einfach eine generelle Konfliktliege?
Ich habe mich ja damals, wie ich das immer so mache, erst mal auf Twitter ausgekotzt. Ich hatte dann plötzlich mit dem Community-Manager von Timberland für Europa zu tun, der mich erst mal gefragt hat. Dem ist erst mal ziemlich der Kiefer gefallen. Das habe ich auch in dem Cash-Talk-Podcast erzählt. Und ich glaube auch im Bluehaha.
Wodurch ist ihm jetzt? Durch deine Reaktionen?
Nee, also erstens, ich habe natürlich gesagt, Timberland, was ist denn das für ein Scheiß, den ihr hier macht? Das geht so nicht. Und dann hat er sich gemeldet, fragte, was genau ist denn das Problem? Dann sage ich, naja, das Problem ist, dass das hier ein breiten Sport ist, dass das nicht als Werbung gekennzeichnet ist, dass die Caches so mal abgelassen. Und dem ist vor allem deswegen der Kiefer gefallen, weil dann hat sich herausgestellt, dass Timberland selbst auch wieder nur eine Agentur beauftragt hat. Die haben für die quasi die Geocaching-Kampagne durchgeführt und haben das offensichtlich dermaßen dilettantisch gemacht, dass es nur nach hinten losgehen konnte, eben weil sie nicht vorher einfach mal Geocacher gefragt haben. Die sind einfach völlig unsensibel da rangegangen. Und das war natürlich deswegen auch ein ganz super Thema für den Prohaar. Völlig daneben, ja. Und er hat sich dann geärgert, weil er hat gesagt, wir haben an dieser Agentur einen ganzen Haufen Geld bezahlt. Und die liefern da so einen Scheiß ab.
Das letzte Projekt, was sie dann gemacht haben.
Er wollte mir dann noch ein paar Schuhe schenken von Timberland, aber das ist nicht so mein Fall. Gut gemeint aber. Und freundlicher auch. Ich finde, es gibt da Grenzen. Also ich persönlich hätte nicht unbedingt was dagegen, wenn es kommerzielle Cashes gäbe. Ich möchte aber gern, dass die so gekennzeichnet sind, dass ich weiß, ich mache einen Werbe-Cash oder dass ich die mir auf die Ignor-Liste setzen kann. Und ich möchte dann auch, dass die Premium-Mitgliedschaft auch günstiger wird oder ganz entfällt. Weil ich finde, dass heute GroundSpeak sich dann entscheiden, welches Geschäftsmodell im Endeffekt jetzt gefahren werden soll.
Lass uns zum Schluss vielleicht nochmal, dass wir nicht so ganz so......ausufern....kantiges Thema hier am Ende stehen haben. Eigentlich haben wir, glaube ich, schon alles ganz gut abgeklappert. Man könnte jetzt wahrscheinlich noch hier in viele Details gehen, was man noch irgendwie erst noch trinken sollte, wenn man da unterwegs ist. Aber was mich noch mal mehr interessieren würde, ist eigentlich so ein bisschen auch diese Ausgangsfrage, so dieses Leben mit Geo, dieses Bezug suchen zur Außenwelt. Es gibt ja auch dieses Open-Street-Map, das hat auch so seine ganz eigene Zielsetzung. Gibt es da so Überschneidungen? Vielleicht nochmal ein bisschen weiter aufzuspannen, so auch so dieses Phänomene wie Foursquare und dieses, weißt du so, also ich und mein Ort. Beobachten wir da gerade irgendeinen gesellschaftlichen Wandel oder wäre das schon zu überhöht, das so zu sehen? Wie viele Überschneidungen gibt es zwischen diesen Szenen? Was entwickelt sich da?
Also gesamtgesellschaftlich finde ich es persönlich jetzt erstmal schwierig, das einzuordnen. Da werden die Gräben sicher erstmal ganz klassisch verlaufen zwischen den Aluhüten und den Post-Privacy-Spakaria, nehme ich mal an. Was jetzt Geocaching anbelangt, es gibt natürlich auch Leute, die machen das nicht, weil es ist ja irgendwo auch ein Bewegungsprofil. Klar, du kannst ja natürlich sehen, wann war jemand irgendwo. Und da gab es auch Fälle von Geocaches, die waren auf Fernmeldemasten, auf eingezäunten Fernmeldemasten, wo am Zaun Schilder dran hingen.
Hier nicht hochklettern.
Hier nicht hochklettern. Und da hat tatsächlich sich auch mal die entsprechende Betreibergesellschaft, die haben das dann gemerkt, haben das eine Weile beobachtet. Die haben dann den Cash-Owner angeschrieben, haben ihn gebeten, herauszugeben, welche Leute den Cash dort gefunden haben. Hat der Cash-Owner nicht gemacht, hat aber den Cash archiviert, soweit ich die Geschichte noch in Erinnerung habe. Aber eine Frage, die wir in der Geocache Podcast Talker Runde mit Jeremy Irish auf der CeBIT dann im kleinen Rahmen noch hatten, war genau diese. Würde GroundSpeak auf Verlangen die wahre Identität hinter den Geocaching nichts rausgeben? Mittlerweile fragt man eh wahrscheinlich bei der NSA an, aber es ist natürlich eine Frage.
Wir wissen mittlerweile, dass sie sich nicht dagegen wehren könnten, wenn die Anfrage kommt. Von daher stellt sich die Frage nicht so richtig, wie die das sehen, sondern ob es nun schon stattgefunden hat oder nicht.
Bei dieser Geschichte mit diesem Fernmeldeturm gab es, so weit ich weiß, auch ein paar Bußgelder, die verhängt wurden.
Tatsächlich.
Irgendwie ging was raus, man weiß aber nicht, wer da wo was geleakt hat. Ob das der Owner war, der dann Schiss gekriegt hat. Den Owner kann ich ja noch am besten verstehen. Du machst da einfach nur dein Hobby, findest das ein bisschen lustig. Und das ist halt ein Kicken auf so einen Fernmeldeturm klettern. Und plötzlich kriegst du hier, ja, wir müssen jetzt aber sagen, wer hier überall war und so. Also der kann sich ja auch noch am wenigsten wehren. Bei BrownSpeaks sehe ich das schon anders.
Na gut, ich meine, er ist ja...
Er ist eine Privatperson.
Ja gut, also wenn er selber belangt wird, dann könntest du ihn natürlich sehr unter Druck setzen. Ansonsten ist das ja nicht seine Plattform und er hat ja nicht die Dienstleistung bereitgestellt, blablabla. Schwierig zu sagen. In solchen Situationen, wo irgendwelche Autoritäten auf dich zuschreiten und sagen, wir haben ein großes schwarzer Helikopter und du bist ein kleines Nichts, jetzt bitte Volksamkeit now, dann wackelt natürlich jeder so ein bisschen. Oder fällt halt auch gleich um. Das kann man den Leuten, glaube ich, nicht unbedingt zum Vorwurf machen. Aber das ist natürlich auf jeden Fall eine Frage, die hier aufkommt. So oder so, aus dem, was wir besprochen haben, geht ohnehin ja auch hervor. Es gibt hier bei all dem Spaß und all dieser Bezugnahme zur Umwelt auch eine ganze Reihe von Grenzen, die zu überschreiten nicht ganz so angemessen ist, was die Sicherheit der Keschenen betrifft, was die Zugänglichkeit von bestimmten, die Verletzlichkeit von Orten betrifft, also Naturschutzgebiete, etc., Höhlen, etc. Das schließt sich natürlich aus.
Es gab mal einen, der ist aus einem fürchterlich langweiligen Wohnviertel weggezogen, weil die Nachbarn ihn dauernd beobachtet haben. Und nachdem er da weggezogen ist, hat er den Geocache mitten in die Straße gelegt. Und der heißt dann auch so, die Rache an meinem Kiez. Kann man alles machen, also das ist schön.
Lustig auf jeden Fall. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall soziale Sprengkraft drin. Auch diese Open Street Map, Entschuldigung, die Google Street Map Debatte, die auch so völlig obskure oder zumindest aus meiner Sicht obskure, aber vielleicht auch nachvollziehbare Ängste da losgetreten hat. Dieses Beobachtet werden, dieses My Home is My Castle und hier darf keiner rein und lalala. Und auf einmal hast du das Gefühl, hier hat ein neuer Bienenstock aufgemacht und es ist irgendwie ein permanentes Fly-in, Fly-out, weil auf einmal so ein Cache oder mehrere aufgetaucht sind. Die 160-Meter-Regel, die verhindern, das will ich auch an der Stelle auch über...
Na ja, ich hab auch schon Caches gesehen, hat dann der Owner geschrieben hier, das Listing ist erstmal disabled auf unbestimmte Zeit, weil hier in der Gegendenetzzeit öfter Einbrüche passiert sind. Und ich möchte nicht, dass die Bewohner nervös werden, weil jetzt hier auch noch Geocacher rumrennen und so rumgucken und so. Das ist halt verdächtig irgendwo. Aber finde ich okay, kann man ja mal ein halbes Jahr warten, wird der Cache halt mal nicht gefunden, dann kann man nochmal gucken, hat sich die Situation gelegt und kann ja dann den Leuten auch sagen, okay, also die suchen jetzt da wieder. Finde ich... oder für Bunker und Höhlen ist natürlich ein Thema immer hier Fledermaus-Schutzzeit. Fängt den 1. Oktober an. Und wenn du da nicht einen gewissenhaften Owner hast, von dem du dich darauf verlassen kannst, dass wenn das den Cache betrifft, er den Cache dann auch disabelt und das auch hinschreibt, dann läufst du halt auch Gefahr, den Fledermaus in ihrem Winterschaft zu stören. Auch nicht so schön, möchte man nicht. Das muss man sich als Owner halt auch drum kümmern. Also für mich persönlich, ich mag gerne dieses Occasion-Base-Zeug, ich finde Foursquare cool, ich mag gerne die Badges bei Foursquare, ich finde die Badges bei GroundSpeak völlig scheiße. Total unterirdisch, geht gar nicht, die sind nicht schön, die werden auch so ganz zufällig nur vergeben, das ist nicht spannend, die bringen keine zusätzlichen Spannungen ins Spiel.
Du meinst jetzt nicht diese Fafs, sondern noch was anderes?
Badges, ja, du kriegst zum Beispiel ein Badge, es gibt Bundesländer-Badges zum Beispiel. Wenn du in einem Bundesland schon mal einen Cash gefunden hast, dann kriegst du dafür ein Badge in dein Profil rein.
Bist du Bürgermeister?
Nee, Bürgermeister nicht, aber du kriegst halt ein Badge. Also ich finde das lustig. Ingres zum Beispiel im Gegenzug dazu ist nicht so meins. Das liegt für mich vor allem daran, dass ich bei Ingres das Gefühl hätte, ich muss einen Ort, den ich schon mal erobert habe, ständig wiedererobern oder den ständig verteidigen. Und das macht mich total wahnsinnig, das will ich nicht machen. Also für mich ist das Schöne am Geocaching, ich habe dann einen Cash gefunden und der ist dann auch runter von der Liste und ich kann dann andere suchen, kann anders hingehen. Aber da ist eben jeder anders, der eine sucht, der andere anders. Dafür hast du bei Ingress natürlich mehr diesen Community-Aspekt. Dann musst du ja mittlerweile schon konzertiert losziehen, damit du da irgendwie, genau.
Wobei es gibt sicherlich auch Caches, wo man nur mit mehreren Leuten Erfolg haben kann, oder?
Naja, auf einem Lost-Base sollte man eh nie alleine gehen, das ist ganz klar. Einen T4-Heiber zum Beispiel kannst du unter Umständen nur mit einer Räuberleiter erreichen, kannst aber auch eine normale Leiter mitnehmen, natürlich.
Ich meine doch jenseits der Gefahr, dass man sowas macht, wie einer muss sich da hinstellen, einer muss sich da hinstellen, und der Dritte guckt dann irgendwie dazwischen oder in der Flucht oder so.
Wir hatten mal einer, der war richtig gut, da hat jemand in ein Schild, also in das Rohr von einem Schild, Straßenschild, ein Paddling reinfallen lassen. Ein Paddling, das ist auch ein Geocache-Behälter, und zwar ist das diese Urform, aus der diese Pad-Flaschen gemacht werden. Dann ist das später rausgeblasen. Das sind so Ovali, die sehen ein bisschen aus wie Reagenzgläser, die sind wasserdicht, die haben ja diesen schönen Schraubverschuss schon oben drauf. Der hält das ja, das ist ja bekannt sozusagen. Der hat so ein Paddling einfach oben in so ein Schildstange reinfallen lassen. Und du konntest den Cache nur rauskriegen, indem du Wasser reingefüllt hast.
Ach, weil er dadurch hochgespült wurde sozusagen?
Genau. Und jetzt ist aber der Trick an der Geschichte, du musst ja nicht nur das Wasser dabei haben, sondern in dem Befestigungsrohr war natürlich ein Loch drin, damit das Wasser wieder abfließen kann. Und ich war da mit einem Kumpel, wir wussten überhaupt nicht, was uns erwartet. Wir sind dann zur nächsten Tanke gefahren, haben einen 5-Liter-Kanister gekauft, haben Wasser reingefüllt, das war am See.
Also das stand in dem Listing drin, Wasser ist erforderlich oder wie?
Ja, ich glaube aber mehr auch nicht, also nicht wie viel und so.
Ihr braucht Wasser, okay.
Wir haben einen 5-Liter-Kanister gekauft, haben den dann am Flussufer aufgefüllt und hatten dann aber nichts, somit wir dieses Loch zu machen konnten. Da hatten wir natürlich erstens den Vorteil, dass wir zu zweit waren, weil ich konnte das Loch zuhalten und der Kollege konnte hochklettern und das Wasser reinkippen, aber nur zuhalten hat halt auch nicht wirklich geholfen. Deswegen haben wir eine Bandschlinge, also der ist mit Bandschlingen auch hoch, am Schild hoch, damit er oben dann rein konnte. Wir haben dann eine Bandschlinge drum gepackt, um das Loch erstmal abzudichten, die haben wir dann mit Duct Tape abgedichtet und ich habe da noch einen Daumen drauf gehalten, damit wirklich nichts rausgeht.
Man ist auf jeden Fall herausgefordert.
Was ich persönlich angenehm finde, ist, ich mache da natürlich auch überall mal Fotos, wenn mir irgendwas gut gefällt und was ich sehr schön finde, ist, dass ich anhand des Datums in den Photo Exif-Daten und anhand der Geocaches, die ich an diesen Tagen gelockt habe, wieder rausfinden kann, wo ich ein Foto gemacht habe. Finde ich persönlich ganz. Nö, ich mache ja nicht. Manche Leute machen Fotos von allem. Die dokumentieren ganz genau jede Station und schreiben auch alles dazu und archivieren das. Was natürlich praktisch ist, weil du kannst sie immer anrufen, wenn du einen Hint brauchst. Oder wenn eine Station kaputt ist. Das ist sehr lohnenswert, so einen Telefonjoker unter den Geocaching-Bekannschaften zu haben. Aber mir persönlich wäre das zu viel. Die schreiben alles ganz genau auf. Wenn sich was ändert, dann dokumentieren sie das auch wieder. Ich habe da irgendwie so einen etwas skurril dubiosen Respekt vor solchen Menschen. Das sind für mich so eine Nordklasse für sich. Geocaching-Dokumentierer.
Tja, wahrscheinlich zählt einfach jeder auch was anderes daraus. Was wahrscheinlich auch dafür spricht, dass das so ein breit gestreutes Teilnehmerfeld ist. Mich hat das ein bisschen überrascht. Ich hätte jetzt damit gerechnet, dass es da irgendeinen Menschenschlag gibt, der da einfach mehr Spaß dran findet als andere. Ich meine, vielleicht fehlt ja auch irgendwas ganz offensichtliches, irgendein Ausschnitt der Gesellschaft, der jetzt daran doch überhaupt nicht teilnimmt. Oder hast du den Eindruck auch nicht?
Also, ich habe mal ein Rentnerpaar getroffen, 60 und 65. Und die waren offensichtlich auch noch gar nicht so lange zusammen. Und dann haben wir beim Geocaching-Stammtisch, wie habt ihr euch denn kennengelernt? Und die haben dann gesagt, wir haben uns ganz normal im Internet auf einer Datingplattform kennengelernt. Und ich so, wie ganz normal im Internet? Und die so, naja, wir wollten damit nur sagen, nicht etwa bei so was Besonderem wie Geocaching oder so sein. Ganz normal im Internet, ja. Solche Menschen trifft man da einfach. Ich finde das fantastisch. Oder ich hätte gedacht, Kinder macht Geocaching prinzipiell immer Spaß, das ist gar nicht so. Wenn Kinder zu lange suchen müssen, die wären total wahnsinnig. Das geht gar nicht. Also schön versteckte Caches oder ein schöner Multi mit einer schönen Geschichte oder so. Das funktioniert überhaupt nicht, wenn nicht alle 300, 400 Meter eine Station ist, die sie leicht finden können und die groß ist, wo ganz viele bunte Überraschungsei-Figuren drin sind. Und das ist ja nun mal meistens der Fall. Dass Überraschungsei-Figuren drin sind. In großen Dosen. Also ein Kinder-Cache ist eine große Dose im Wald, das finden die super. Also schnell hingehen, ein bisschen ab vom Weg an einen Baumstumpf und dann guckt man in eine tolle große Dose und oh, Lillifee und so und dann alles schick.
Also Schnitzeljagd ist ja dann auch mal so der Kindergeburtstagsspaß.
Aber coole Geschichte oder geschichtlich interessanter Cache oder schöner Lost Place oder in einem schönen Garten oder so. Völlig boring, kriegst du die Kleinen nicht mit.
Kann ich mir vorstellen, da muss man schon so ein bisschen die Fähigkeit haben, auch so ein bisschen die Längen und die Beharrlichkeit dann auch auszuspielen. So, Beharrlichkeit haben wir jetzt hier auch gezeigt.
Ja, wir sind ganz schön lange, wa?
Naja, wie das so ist hier, ne? Bis das halt alles besprochen ist. Ich hab so den Eindruck, da sind wir jetzt so langsam gelandet und haben noch was wichtiges.
Wir können ja mal noch einen Geocache-Zoom gehen. Du hast doch bestimmt noch keinen. Du hast doch auf deinem Profil noch gar keinen gefunden. Das sehe ich doch.
Ich bin der totale Muggel-Noob.
Ja, seh ich auf deinem Profil. Du hast ja noch nichts.
Nackt im Internet. Hat nichts gefunden, weiß nicht, versteckt nichts. Keine Ahnung. Kommt Zeit, kommt Cash. Regine, vielen Dank.
Ja, ich hab zu danken. War ein sehr angenehmer Mittag.
Genau, jetzt haben wir es dir auch mal alles festgehalten. Und ihr da draußen, viel Spaß. Noch weiterhin vielen Dank erstmal fürs Zuhören. Das war CRE. Ihr wisst es, es geht irgendwann auch wieder weiter. Bleibt betreut.